No headphones.
I'd rather not have that gene.
Grazie no,
because I learned that,
I learned that the hearing my own voice
in my head makes,
makes me focus on it and I don't want to
focus on the sound of my voice.
I want to focus on your thoughts.
I'm focusing on,
Ooh,
it's like blowing out in my head and all
this shit's going on.
That's smart.
What's up?
Oh,
we're talking about whether or not you
should have headphones on or not have
headphones on.
Don't are we up?
No.
If you're hearing the audio recording in
this,
what's happening is we switched to a new
tri caster.
We were having problems with our old one
to tri caster is the machine that allows
Jamie to switch cameras and put
everything up on the Internet and
hopefully includes skype so we could get
some people from like getting signal,
but there's no video showing.
Hmm.
Are we going to restart?
I don't know.
I'm trying to make sure that that's
actually true.
Sorry.
It's okay.
Uh,
we might have to restart.
Folks would try and live while we're
going live with some new shit.
But I want it.
I want people on Youtube.
Is it audio?
But no video.
I don't know why I figured that out.
Ladies.
Gentlemen,
if you are just staring at a blank
screen,
would you have to shut this?
Showed down to get the video back to it
should work,
but all right,
just do a double camera.
A two shot.
So you're never going to be okay now.
Is it live now?
Tech motherfucking,
they would suck.
It would suck if like we did back in
half an hour.
It turns out none of it got picked up or
we did a whole shore.
Camera's going on youtube right now for
sure.
It just,
they don't see us right now.
He's trying to fix that
motherfucking dollar.
Gee,
we were having problems with our old tri
caster crashing a lot.
So we've got a new tri caster,
but it turns out that,
what is it that doesn't match up?
What part is wrong?
The control panel.
It should be okay.
Hey everybody.
Oh Shit.
Um,
what were we just talking about?
We're talking about material,
headphones,
headphones.
Oh,
listening to yourself and the
headphones.
What I think of is though,
it makes me like I close out the outside
world.
Totally.
And I just lock in on the conversation.
Yeah,
it's only psychological.
But if you will watch,
if he puts up a video,
it'd be nice to hear it and then you
brought your head and you have to put
the headphones on.
I just feel like when that's on,
it's just like I pay more attention to
not talking over people too.
Can't stand the sound of my voice.
So hearing you,
thank you.
Thank you.
But I can't stand the sound of it and I,
I hear enough.
I don't need it blasting in my ears as I
talked.
Then I focus on it and then I think
that's a good get depressed.
It's a good quality to,
he hate your own voice because voice,
he would listen to it all the time like,
Ooh,
you know how hard it is to listen to my
standup.
That's tyree hard for everybody.
It's death.
It kills me.
But I,
but I always
hear your voice.
You've got to listen to your shit.
You got to go back and edit,
you got to edit your shit.
And I'm like,
I don't want to listen to my self.
I just,
I want to put every,
uh,
every time I go up on stage behind me,
I don't want to go back.
But I know that's not the right thing to
do.
You,
you get a,
you take a lot of time out of the
development of a joke process if you
just listened to the previous versions
of it.
Cause like I have this new bit that I'm
doing right now.
Um,
and I have like three different versions
of it and it's not right now.
It's very shaky.
It goes one way,
it goes the other way.
Sometimes it gets a big laugh.
Sometimes it's just,
it's just clunky and I've got to figure
out which one's the right formula.
So the only way to do that really is to
listen to how I did it.
Right.
And then play it back and then write it
out.
I'll listen to how I said it and I'll
write it out.
And then I'll think about like what
would,
I would be thinking if I was sitting
there listening to this or if someone
was saying this,
you know what,
I anticipate what they're saying with
the punchlines are going to be
beforehand.
Because if you do that takes a lot out
of it.
You know?
It's got to find a way to sneak it in.
You've got to find a way to make it
where it really relates recordings or
ever have an uh,
an old bit that you like an old one from
like 10,
15 years ago that you'd think like,
damn,
I should have added that adding shit to
it today.
Oh yeah man,
if you kept going,
that's like the argument like already
had a good point about that.
He was like,
if you just keep adding to your bits and
making them better and that's why you
don't want to release a special,
you could have used that same creativity
to come up with new bits instead of
doing the same old bits for 10 years.
You could have used that.
You know,
cause there's some guys that think that
like if you got those old old,
old bits there,
Samurai swords,
man,
they'd just been hammering down and
Polish type
this,
they have this rhythm to them.
You're like Jesus Christ.
Like I remember,
um,
I did,
uh,
did a special once and I rent,
I didn't have like hardly any new
material and so there's like 2009 inch
or something like that.
So I did some of my old old shit from
like 1,999 tiger bit.
No,
no,
no.
It was uh,
some other stuff.
What I didn't,
I didn't do that,
but when I retired that bit,
I retired that but bringing that,
you can always bring that back,
bring that back.
It's over.
But uh,
but I remember thinking,
damn,
these are these old 10 year old bits.
And I had for like literally 10 years
before I did my first recording.
I started in 88 and I recorded in like
99 so almost 11 years for actually
recording anything there are so tight
because I had been,
I'd never done them on anything so I
could do them all the time.
Yeah,
I do.
I'm on the road or just they would just,
Yup,
Yup.
Yeah.
You learn how that path,
you got a fucking Ninja.
It's unconscious.
Yeah.
I love your description of what you were
talking about,
tying your shoes like you know how many
tire shoes you don't think this loops
going in here and this is going here and
then I'm going to bring it here and then
he just like that you wouldn't even
be able to eat.
You couldn't even teach it to someone
over the phone rings and it's teaching
me over the phone and be like,
I got to do it a few times first and
figure out what the hell I'm doing
because I don't even know what I'm
doing.
I have no idea what I'm doing when I
talk about shoes and I do it every day.
My son,
when he learned to tie her shoes like
maybe six months ago,
it was,
he never wanted to,
he's like,
he wants to do everything.
He wants to decide where we eat every
day,
but he doesn't want to tie his own shoe
laces.
So,
um,
we finally made him,
he,
you know,
and he was happy.
He was struggling with it.
And I use that as an opportunity to,
to show him how you can master anything.
Anything that you're having trouble
with.
Go look right now you're having trouble
that you could do what he could do it,
but he,
he struggles.
So one day you're going to do it like
Daddy,
like,
oh daddy does it.
I'm not even looking at my shoes.
Look and I do it and go boom.
And he's like,
I got to look at that crazy.
Isn't that crazy?
I'll do it again.
Look my other shoe and I do.
And he's like,
Whoa,
how'd you do that Daddy?
That's like magic.
And I go,
I go,
you can do it.
To Watch one day you'll go do it and
you're not even going to look.
So like the next day he's trying not to
look.
He's like,
Daddy,
I'm not looking.
Look,
hoodies,
he struggled,
but now he's got it that then now I
could use that,
that whole story that he won't forget
it.
Go.
Remember that.
Remember when you had trouble tying your
shoes and remember how good you can look
how you are now this is the same thing,
whether it's gymnastics or break dancing
or Jujitsu,
karate,
whatever we do,
it's,
it's the same exact thing.
Your body is magic.
You just got to tell it a thousand times
and then if I only listens and it'll do
it itself.
I thought about that today.
Not Today,
but like now look,
if someone,
if I had to learn today how to do like a
three 60 roundhouse kick.
Yeah.
At 50 years old I'd be like,
what?
What am I going to do?
Yeah.
I'd be like,
what are you doing?
But when I do it,
it just like,
it's just something I've done my whole
life.
Just Push,
you know,
it's like a dance and your bits,
like you were talking about like I bits
that you've been like your Noah's Ark
bit was so god Damn Tigers,
we were on the road,
you know,
back back in the day we were on the,
if you went on the road,
I hung out with you.
I went on the road and you know,
every,
if you weren't on the road,
we were at the comedy store every
weekend.
You weren't on the road.
So I saw your,
your act over and over and over to the
point where I wasn't listening to the
jokes no more.
I was listening to the audience
reaction.
That was what was entertaining.
I got to sit through another hour of
your shit.
So for me,
I,
uh,
I started,
being entertained by the audience.
Like,
which jokes work and,
and it's very,
it's fascinating when,
you know,
there's women out there,
they'd go out there and they had to drag
their husband out.
He didn't want to go out.
He wanted to stanch cause we,
you never take me out.
And she dragged him out.
He spent a lot of money there.
They're buying money,
they're buying drinks,
she
wants to make sure that they have a
great time.
So there's always like 10 of those wives
that dragged their husbands out and they
just want a lab.
So it's,
they're,
they're laughing at stuff that isn't the
punchline.
And you,
you,
uh,
there was so many things that you would
say that just,
just the way you set them and wasn't,
it wasn't the,
the joke at all,
but there'd be like four chicks for just
laugh and they're like ready to laugh,
you know?
Well,
people that love standup comedy,
you definitely can get into like certain
rhythms,
but then you can,
it's like everything else,
right?
Like you,
you like one level of comedy,
like one kind of comedy,
but then you see a bunch of comedians
and then the original stuff that you
liked you'd think sucks.
Oh yeah.
I used to think comic view was the
funniest shit.
I was obsessed with coffee.
My whole life was all about music.
But my,
my two side things,
we're fighting.
I love boxing.
Ever since I was a kid.
I was a huge,
gigantic box and fan.
Then I got into the UFC,
but uh,
and then comedy,
it was a,
all I taped all I tape at home on my vcr
was comedy specials and Tuesday night
fights any kind of boxing.
And it was just comedy,
comedy and fights where my hobby and
music was the goal.
That was my life.
I take comm anytime comicview was on
that I have which ones?
Comic view.
It was all black.
Is that bet?
Yes.
Is that the one that deals you will use
to host?
Okay.
And,
and uh,
you know,
uh,
live at the Apollo,
the def comedy jam.
I was the biggest fan of black comedy.
The biggest fan.
I mean,
you know,
right away.
And then you look back at like some of
those,
the standups after hanging out with you
though and all,
I started going,
Oh shit.
Okay.
That's load up all the,
a lot of those guys who are low level,
well it's just,
there's,
there's premises that just get,
you know,
there's,
there's guys out there like bill burr or
Dave Chappelle or the real high level
guys that are seeing things and then
they're commenting on things and they're
pointing things out that maybe other
people didn't notice.
Then there's other people that are doing
bits because they know other people have
done bits on that subject successfully.
So it's not totally stealing,
but they're not really being creative.
They're just like trying to recreate
some mat.
There's a few guys that do that.
Like you,
you hear them and you go,
man,
you know that Bill Hicks did a bit about
that.
Like you know that this guy did a bit
about that.
Like I see what you're doing.
Like you're trying to like read,
like you don't have your own original
point.
A lot of those shows were like that.
They were just trying to make it,
cause it was the comedy boom man.
Well you're talking about was like there
was a comedy tv boom that included
evening at the Improv.
MTV,
half hour comedy hour spotlight,
lot spotlight live on vh one some Friday
night thing they had on Fox that uh,
used to be at the laugh factory.
They still have a police show.
It was crazy.
There was so much comedy,
it was out of control,
but there was a lot of guys that just
didn't belong in the business yet.
I mean,
I couldn't say that it couldn't
eventually have broke,
but they were basically like,
did you ever notice,
hey like there's a lot of those fucking
guys where they would like,
hey and there's a Goddamn wild kingdom
plan out my live in Rome.
Like they had this like comedy rhythm
that they would do,
but they didn't have shit to say.
But it's still worth a lot of those guys
were doing comedy to get a Sitcom.
They weren't tracking,
they didn't really want to do comedy.
Exactly.
They thought it'd be easier if they did
it that way.
Well,
there was a lot of actors that I talked
to about it.
They're like,
Hey Matt,
for me it's real hard to get auditions.
And he goes in for the longest time,
I'd sit around and watch you guys get
development deals and I'd be like,
fuck that.
These guys don't even act.
And then I realized like,
why am I complaining?
Why don't I just do what they do?
How hard could it be?
Yeah,
it's hard.
It's so easy.
Sam Aaa did a special last week at the
viper room and Hollywood man,
we've known Sam forever.
I don't know.
I have known him for 15 years or
something like that.
Maybe longer.
God Damn Dude,
God damn this exam special.
It was his first special,
you know,
it took them 10 years to get his shit
together.
But holy fuck,
that hour slammed beautiful.
She did is a viper two washes.
That's a great place to film a special
man.
It was.
I stayed for both shows.
He did.
You know when you film you do too,
like you know,
just in case something goes wrong and he
would do some stuff to,
it was weird.
I've never seen a comic before.
He fuck up a bit and go,
wait a minute,
let's do that one again and then start
again and do that like three times.
He just wanted to make sure it was
perfect.
You know what I mean?
Because the response was so great.
The he was just on stage.
He couldn't even believe it.
He couldn't,
everybody was dying in Edwards was
there.
Beautiful.
Yeah,
it was,
he,
it's really good to see him,
uh,
blossom.
I think that,
you know,
based on the Netflix specials that I see
on average three minutes at a time,
I mean a lot of bad ones,
they're just putting out comedy specials
left and right.
My random dudes you never heard of,
and a lot of,
a of a lot of super vanilla,
Netflix,
comedy specials,
Vanilla,
like they're not going beep,
beep.
There's the little bit of that going on.
And there's also,
I think people need to fill more shows.
I think they're just filming one show
sometimes.
Sometimes too.
I really think if you can afford each
should do for Ricky Gervais is his new
one.
I was never a giant fan of,
has never really paid attention to him.
Like Ricky Gervais'.
Then you do like cartoons or something
like that.
His new special on Netflix.
That one is a grand slam.
He's fucking good.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
That's awesome.
Can you see Chappelle's Oh yeah,
those are great.
Yeah.
How about the one in the belly row
about,
I mean I was there for that one.
Do you remember how we ended that shit?
Basically telling people exactly why he
went to Africa.
That's pretty crazy.
That took balls as dangerous shit.
Well he's really knows fuck.
I mean cat willy,
he's doing a specialist pretty good too.
I didn't like that one as much.
I didn't like it as much as I liked his
other ones.
He spent the first 20 minutes on
Jacksonville cause that's where he
filmed it and I thought,
you know,
okay,
I see what he's doing.
But he had some,
I thought he had some pretty good stuff
considering that,
you know,
all the crazy stuff he went through.
I thought maybe he'll never be back and
he's just going to be like insane or
whatever.
But he did.
He did come back and he is,
I'm a big fan of his
bolt,
salt stuff.
Some of the best.
Oh my God.
The pimp chronicles.
Come on.
Yes.
Katt Williams.
Katt Williams was a,
is one of the guys that if I'm just,
I don't have shit to listen to in my
car,
I just put youtube and just Katt
Williams,
just some random bit.
I,
if I don't have anything to go,
he's like,
he's a Goto.
Yeah,
he's a Goto for sure.
It's a good time,
man.
Good time for you.
And now the comedy store's unfucking
believable.
It's nothing like we used to hang out
there every day and the early 2000 and
2000 2001 before 10th planet was even a
thought.
My life consisted of deejaying at strip
clubs for money at home,
trying to make it,
you know,
in music and hanging out with you doing
comedy,
you know,
it's crazy.
That was crazy.
And you think about that,
pleasure is always half empty.
Yes it was.
It was like a dying dinosaur.
It was ready to go and shit was ready to
go.
And then when you add that men see a
shit and you left man,
that the place was,
it was like,
how is it surviving like right there on
sunset,
such prime at the prime spot.
You could put a giant hotel there.
How's that place not going to get
knocked down?
And then when you came back,
I remember asking you a couple of times
and that,
that seven year absence or whatever it
was going,
do you ever get to go back to the comedy
store?
Because I wanted you to to go back and
you were like,
fuck that.
I ain't called back.
You were like really?
Like,
you know,
you felt like you got really screwed by
them and you did.
Those mother fuckers turned their back
on you at the comedy store and took that
dude side and now looking back,
they know they made a big mistake.
So you were like,
you standing in Goddamn ground like fuck
that.
I'll go to the ice house.
So I'll go to Improv,
fuck the congress store.
And then you came back man.
And it's in,
it's like,
uh,
a different world.
Literally a different world.
Like,
it's fucking booman is selling out every
goddamn night.
Bolt rooms are packed.
It's like,
uh,
it's like,
it's unbelievable.
Like you couldn't,
nobody would believe that shit.
It's so alive at the comedy store.
People just go there like during the
week,
like it's a big event.
Tuesday nights,
Tuesday,
Tuesday nights sometimes they have two
sold out shows.
Khurram and the original,
the comedy chaos Tuesdays.
Yeah.
The father's never been like that,
but no,
it was buck.
They opened up all those,
those old decrepit brooms and made a
bark.
Like they're opening up a everything's,
there's all these bar that used to be a
video room.
That back bar is the best he can get
away from people and chill out back
there.
Yeah.
That she wasn't around back in the
[inaudible].
That was probably the whole smoking car
door in the back now.
Yeah.
But he goes out back to south side,
the outside bar.
It's booming.
There's always people there drinking.
It's,
it's crazy weird.
Right.
The Bar's always mobbed.
It helps nuggets.
And then across the street,
House of Blues,
they knock that shit down.
Like when you walk outside and you go up
that ramp,
you know that ramp is and the parking
lot next door and get that views insane.
Yeah,
the view's incredible.
Like they have the best view in the
world.
Comedy stores like,
um,
it's like guns and roses slam big and
the fucking eighties disappeared for 20
fucking years.
25 years.
And now guns and roses not only made a
comeback,
but they're bigger than ever.
They're bigger than ever.
It guns and roses.
Unbelievable.
Everywhere they play,
they're just sell it out and it's in,
I saw him in Mexico City and got
completely blown away.
I was like Mexico City,
we there for seminar.
I was there for combat.
You Tony's fight.
That's crazy.
You saw.
Yeah,
that brings us,
oh,
it was incredible.
And I was never a giant guns and roses
fan.
I respected them.
I like their songs and shit.
But you know,
as a kid,
once one of your friends claims them as
their favorite and now they can't be
your favorite.
So it's like some stupid shit.
It's some stupid shit.
Like my friend Matt,
he claimed guns and roses and I'm like,
okay,
cause we wouldn't,
if,
if he bought a guns and roses record,
I would just tape it.
I wouldn't buy it too.
So whoever actually own that,
the master,
you know what I mean?
That was their band,
Fuck you.
That's my band.
It's like a sport.
It really is.
But you have a bunch of teams like
yours.
My band was kiss cause I,
even when everyone made fun of him,
I'm the only one who admitted they still
liked him for a while.
Then you get like that with boxers to
no,
with boxing was different.
It was boxing is all racist.
It's completely racist.
And it's okay.
Boxing's the only sport,
it's the only sport you could be racist,
black guy will not ever have generally
is bummer general.
It was Donald Curry getting knocked out
by Mike Mcowen,
Mike,
Mike Tyson font.
When Mike Tyson fought Gerry Cooney,
every white guy,
white guy did Mike Tyson.
I saw what a bunch of white guys,
but not anybody famous.
No,
not really.
Um,
anybody.
Well,
uh,
Gelada coolish guy who was,
that's right.
That's right.
But does he comes wipe?
Yeah,
he's from Poland.
A lot of them is pretty well times the
European whites.
We don't think of them as American war.
The animals.
Yeah,
we definitely,
yeah,
we want like Russians are always going
to go for the Russian guy.
So boxing is the only one.
Like I didn't give a fuck who the
Mexican was fighting.
I'm going for the Mexican.
Even if I didn't know the Mexican,
I already had love for him.
Yeah,
he wasn't Mexican and he was Panamanian.
That's good enough.
Right.
If he was Argentinian,
you know one role,
Dan,
remember him.
I remember Argentina,
that guys,
if he's fighting a Mexican,
I'm going for the Mexican.
But if he's fighting a white guy or a
black guy,
I'm always going for the Latin guy.
That the only sport where you could be
totally racist.
My best friend was black growing up and
we,
we both watched boxing together and he
always went for the black guy.
I always went for the Latin guy and it
was like,
it was okay.
There was nothing wrong with that.
Who was another a Argentinian champion
that was champion before?
Um,
Marvin Hagler.
God Damn it.
It's at the tip of my tongue.
I cannot remember.
His name was Pepino.
Cuevas.
Alexis are guayle.
As long as there were Latin,
there were Mexican to me.
He was right before Marvin Hagler.
God dammit.
I see him.
I see his curly hair.
A handsome and fellow calls Mons on.
Thank God I got it.
It was great.
Pull it up.
Jamie's going to pull it up before I go.
Remember [inaudible] zone was a bad
mother fucker,
wasn't he from Argentina?
It was beautiful.
Yeah.
He was a tough guy,
man.
There was a,
those are the blood and guts days of
boxing.
You know,
Roberto Duran can be candidate
lightweight,
135 pound killers.
It was a different world back then,
man.
Those guys were tough as shit.
15 round fights is different though.
I always,
I was always the,
I,
there was a point where I thought
generally overall just black people are
way funnier than white people based on
stand up comedy.
I was like,
give,
this was like a little Richard Pryor.
Eddie Murphy,
you know,
I really believe that.
And like Mexican communities.
I wasn't like rooting for Paul
Rodriguez.
I was like,
oh good.
I was,
I didn't,
yeah,
I know some people do,
but I didn't.
I was,
I,
uh,
you know,
now he's just against the white and see
him more than anything.
When people found out it wasn't really
Mexican,
they were like,
what?
He's on Dorian.
Ron during a German or something.
Yeah.
Did he ever see some Mexican?
Yes.
Yeah.
He was like,
he doesn't anymore.
It was like an end.
Andrew dice clay,
he was kind of raised by Mexican people
though.
He should,
he should have said that.
And he said,
listen,
this isn't all,
it's just this like,
it's my character.
I'll change your name.
Carlis I'm calling them and see.
I couldn't,
we change Andrew dice clay.
Yeah,
but that's first of all,
that's like a character name,
but I'm saying like saying your
ethnicity,
maybe Carlos.
I had to put tape on my eyes and trying
to save his Kareo Chan.
He would be like,
what?
Right?
You can't do that.
But if you try to claim,
if I tried to claim German,
right,
just out of nowhere,
like you don't know any better,
you'd never see my 23 and now maybe you
did like a [inaudible] character where
you're,
could you do German accent?
Not Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Uh,
that's Austrian.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Um,
no.
I don't think I could probably do one if
I may.
The Arnold so easy.
So like I can only do sir.
I can't do trump,
man.
You can't do trump.
No,
I can't do it at all.
My voice doesn't make those sounds like
I'm
not a good impressionist.
I'm just good at the ones that I can do.
What does Arnold think?
A trump busy.
We've had this conversation before is
not a bad guy.
He's just a guy.
Oh,
that's right.
He's listening.
He's doing what everybody wants.
He's making billions.
He's fucking porn stars.
And you're mad at him.
This is the fucking American Jean who
looks like Bro.
For real though,
who looks like him and fucks like he
does.
I,
I'm a little bit more impressed with
donald after all the scandals.
It backfired.
You guys will try and go,
no Clinton on this guy.
He's not trying to fuck kids so that,
hey,
here's a thing about it,
like Roseanne Barr,
they were saying that Roseanne Barr was,
uh,
was talking about some conspiracy
theories that have been disproven.
This is what some thing,
cause she was talking about trump,
break it up,
child sex rings.
But he really did spend a lot of time
concentrating on that and having people
go out and try to break up the sex rings
and sex trafficking.
Like this is not something that is a
conspiracy theory.
This is something that he's discussed
many times.
It's also not a conspiracy that there's
sex trafficking.
So as much as you want to discount
trump,
here's a problem that I have with people
that are on the left right now.
They didn't do not looking at
everything,
throwing,
looking at what they want to look at.
He's bad for the environment.
He's always lying.
He cheats on his wife.
He does this,
he does that.
They say all these things that he does
bad.
But when something comes up,
like Roseanne says,
ah,
I'm giving him the benefit of the doubt
because he's going after sex trafficking
and then it turns out all these other
people.
So that's conspiracy theory.
That's a bullshit online.
No,
he said it.
He's put effort into it.
Like you gotta give the Guy Credit
because if you don't give them credit
for things that he does at are
important,
nobody's going to listen to you when
you're criticizing them either because
you,
all you're trying to do is when you're
not trying to look at the thing for what
it really is.
Yeah.
He's this guy and he's not perfect
person,
but he did make note on many times about
at wanting to break up stuff,
just sex trafficking rings.
You know that you're,
uh,
your kid is 20,000 times more likely to
get kidnapped them to get shot or to
school.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
At 20,000 it's conservative.
It's probably really like 70,000,
because if you go by the numbers,
800,000 to a million kids go missing
every year in the United States.
And I looked that up though.
That doesn't,
I'd never found a source for that.
You said that before and I looked that
up and I couldn't find that.
It wasn't nearly as,
I read it online so it could be wrong.
It cause a problem with these things,
like when we say,
especially if you say it,
I'm like right now 2 million people are
going to listen to this or whatever.
The fucking knows.
Even if it's a 100,100 if it's 102
hundred kids,
that's more than school.
One of y'all.
To my point,
it's more than school shootings.
Like what would you rather have your,
you know what's worse?
I don't know what's worse.
Get having your Kubrick shot at any,
right.
Look at this.
According to the National Center for
missing exploited children,
citing US Department of Justice report,
nearly 800,000 children
are reported missing each year.
That's more than 2000 a day.
The end.
See Mec says 203,000 children are
kidnapped each year by family members.
Oh,
family.
That's a little bit of six thousand six
hundred thousand.
Yeah,
that'd be 600,000.
So what's worse has always having your
kid,
cause uh,
cause the conspiracy theory is that
there's this giant international child
sex trafficking network going on that is
being covered up.
That's what's going on.
And if you look at a Jimmy Salvo in the
UK that brought a lot of light to what's
going saddle savile.
Yeah.
That was a terrifying story.
The story with him is Jimmy Savile.
He's dead now.
He died in his eighties at,
in 2011.
He was uh,
uh,
a super famous like Dick Clark kind of
guy.
He was a d,
he was the host of a pop top of the
pops.
Um,
it's like if your band got on that show,
you're going to be mega.
He was huge.
He was friends with the royal family,
with the prime minister's Margaret
Thatcher,
Tony Blair,
a picture of him.
He looks disgusting.
Pull up Jimmy savile.
This guy looks like a child.
Look at this guy.
I was just super fucked by that guy.
Check this out.
But he was 12 super,
super famous and you know what he would
do?
He would raise money for hospitals and
specifically psychiatric hospitals and
he would bring the queen of England and
he got all this power to raise millions
for these hospitals,
these mental institutions.
He,
that's what he prayed on it for kids,
so he would,
what he would do is he would,
he would do so much for these hospitals
that he would put himself on the board
and give himself a job.
They're in a position and he would hang
out at these hospitals.
There's all,
there's at least five.
There's at least 500 people that have
come forward to say they've been were
raped by him.
When that ran a 500 people,
at least it's in the thousands so that
he's holding up on his neck.
What does that say to me?
Oh yeah,
he would fix it.
He worked,
he worked for the BBC,
super famous super,
and he would,
he had Christmas dinner with Margaret
Thatcher Multiple Times.
What does that red hat?
He's got the,
it looks like a maggot hat right above
that.
Yeah.
There's a crazy guy who it turns out he
was a child rapist.
Yeah.
And um,
that's the same thing with Sandusky and
the covering Husky guy it up.
The question is becoming this old dude.
Yes.
Because people knew they're complicit
and they then trump the mystery.
The mystery is how is he so tight with
the prime ministers,
the royal family,
all these politicians,
all this shit comes out when he died.
Cause every time there would be an
allegation while he was alive,
she would just sit them down and go,
what are you going to do now?
I'm going to ruin your life.
You better drop this shit.
What are you going to do?
You think they're going to come after
me?
You know how many millions are given
this hospital?
So he would just shut everything down.
Right.
And there was all these underground
covered up allegations.
Did getting knighthood was a relief
because it got me off the hook.
What does that mean?
You got me off.
He was knighted.
So got him off the hook.
What do you think is that he got
knighted when you get knighted?
Could they,
could they not arrest you anymore?
Is that what happens?
Is it like being the president?
Yeah,
there's a,
there's a documentary on Youtube called
the ninth circle.
Jimmy Savile,
You find out why they covered it up.
Why did they cover it up?
Widen this agent,
Dj these.
It's like Dick Clark.
They should've just mashed them up.
Why was it all being covered up?
It's fucking insane.
When you find out why has it for dead
bodies in general,
the key dead people.
Why he loved fucking dead people.
What'd you hear this then the nights are
green.
The ninth circle to watch that Jesus
Christ.
It's insane.
When you find out when you watch that
shit dude,
it is crazy that you like you're saying
this and it sounds like,
like it can never be possible.
It sounds like it never,
it could be possible that some giant
television star that worked with
children.
It was always helping out.
Children could have actually been
fucking them the whole time and a bunch
of them,
hundreds of raping them and then people
must have known.
There's no way to everybody.
He was killing them too.
He was killing him.
He was killing them,
dude.
They got,
they found all these bodies.
It's a [inaudible].
It's a big scandal in the UK.
Hold up right now.
Look,
Jesus Christ,
there's an island called Jersey island.
It's owned by the Queen and look into
that shit.
I don't even want to get that.
I don't even want to get that deep into
it because that I don't have a rape
children as young as nine while working
at BBC leaked report on veils.
And this is in the independent.
Yeah.
How come?
Why not?
How come there's not the same kind of
effort for this kind of stuff like there
is with the um,
um,
the gun shooting,
the Florida school shooting.
Why isn't there,
because that's not a big event where
it's one thing where all the deaths
happen in one deaths or deaths.
I understand.
I'm with you.
But I mean this is also why people don't
freak out about 500,000 people dying
every year because of obesity.
Like what would you,
what's worse?
What's worse?
Having your kid get shot at a school
shooting or having that motherfucker
rape your daughter and multiple times
and then kill it.
I don't think what's worse.
They're both hard.
Exactly.
It's horrible.
What's scary is that that is being
protected.
Yes.
There's someone that either knew about
it and now he's trying to cover their
ass because they knew about it.
That was the thing about Sandusky.
Y'All saying Guskey did the same thing.
He was raping all these kids and the
whole time he was running these programs
for underprivileged children and helping
all these orphaned kids.
You've got to watch your kids,
man.
You got to watch a he away with abusing
children and sex with dead bodies.
Whoa.
Hanging out with the queen.
Did this guys tight with the cooking
them to God
and all these little kids around him?
You know what you want me to tell you
why he got,
why they left him alone?
You do know according to the ninth
circle,
what does the ninth sorts,
it's a documentary about the whole thing
I'll cover on because everybody's doing
it.
They're all doing it.
He was supplying everybody with kids.
That's what he used the hospitals for.
Well this is not a new theory.
This is not a new theory when it comes
to like groups of freaks.
He was a pimp.
He was supplying everybody with kids.
This is,
this is something that people have
talked about,
like very intelligent people that I know
that have talked about in terms of like,
uh,
there's been stories about people that
have taken politicians to like islands
and shit because that's where they keep
like young girls.
You know,
I don't know why I'm looking at you
jammy dude.
And you know what,
but there's,
but someone talked to me about this and
they were saying,
you have to understand that if you are
in a group of incredibly wealthy people
and you have extreme,
a desire for extreme sexual scenarios,
whips and,
and you can't,
whatever the fuck it is,
you can't young girls,
you can't let anybody know about this.
So people come into these people's lives
that can facilitate these things and
then they developed a sort of bond of
silence.
And this is how when this shit gets out
of hand,
you can get a Jimmy savile or you can
get a Jerry Sandusky.
They'll say one thing about [inaudible]
there was like,
this is not,
sky was not on his own.
Like he was supplying chill iceberg.
Wasn't that one of the things they,
that doesn't come up San Dusky Google
sent Dusky was supplying children to
other pedophiles because that was
something that was also speculated about
some of the donors that were donors to
his,
uh,
his charities.
We're also somehow involved in molesting
those kids.
You know what a death right?
Is death ride,
death ride.
No.
Jimmy savile would supply 10,
15 boys to a certain politician.
Um,
he'd have a boat,
he'd take them out on the boat.
He couldn't,
he couldn't afford to have any
witnesses.
So those were always the last rides.
Those kids would take their called death
rides.
She couldn't have ways.
This is from that same documentary ninth
circle c,
but how do they know that for a fact?
You just got to watch it and,
and uh,
and make the,
uh,
conclusion.
I'm not low.
I'm not ruling it about to get shit
back.
So you got to look at him like a
prosecuting attorney,
not a defense lawyer.
He's already a shitbag.
He's already confirmed already ripping
kids.
What's the stop of killing?
Exactly.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's a good point because if you're
the type of person that could rate a
child,
what can't you do?
And that's what I'm saying,
right?
In the UK,
the numbers could be wrong,
but I heard that every three seconds a
child is reported missing in the UK,
ever.
That's 175,000 kids a year get reported
missing in the,
in the UK,
it's a big businessman has got to be
more than that.
It's a Jochen's in a year.
Isn't that every three seconds at
175,000 that seems low.
Every three minutes.
I'm sorry,
39 every three seconds.
I'm sorry.
Is Crazy.
Every three minutes,
every three minutes.
This is according to something I saw.
31 million seconds in a day.
Yeah.
Um,
I'm sure the numbers are probably a
hundred.
175,000 isn't as big as 800,000 a year,
but damn,
that's,
that should be pick up on all this out.
What we're doing for the Florida
shooting and for the shootings and what
that David Hogg Guy Come on man.
That that's what's scary is that people
are buying all that stuff,
buying all what stuff?
The whole gun control propaganda.
You know,
it's so obvious.
It's,
it's,
it's ridiculous.
It's ridiculous thing to gun control.
Propagandas it's really simple,
man.
It's like they've been,
you have to disarm the population and
that's what they're doing.
And by Ann's trying to disarm it,
they used to say,
oh no,
we just want some restrictions and some
background checks.
Now they're just saying it.
You know,
some people are saying revoke the second
amendment.
They're tearing the constitution.
Those four kids,
those four kids,
there's a concept.
They weren't,
they weren't,
that's not true.
No,
no.
That's photoshop.
No it isn't.
Yeah.
Original image that that girl was
tearing.
It was like a target target.
Okay.
Someone replaced that image with the
constant.
Okay,
but they're essentially doing the same
thing.
Yeah.
No,
I know what you're saying.
They look,
first of all,
they're 17 they were at a school that
got shot up.
Their friends died.
I get it from their point of view.
If I was 17 I would think,
and also they got cameras in their face
and everybody's paying attention to them
and ever.
The New York Times is interviewing on
the Washington Post.
Everyone's calling them up.
If I was them,
I'd probably be doing the same thing.
You would probably too,
if you were in high school with those
kids and all that shit went down.
I don't blame them by any stretch of the
imagination.
I don't even blame people that are
trying to revoke the second amendment.
The thing that infuriates me the most is
that all people want to look at is the
guns.
That's all they want to look at.
You need to look at the mental health of
individuals that are willing to fucking
shoot up a group of kids.
Like why?
Why the fuck would someone do that?
Psychiatric medications are a big one
that if you bring up people roll their
eyes like,
oh,
this again.
There are massive changes to the fucking
chemical composition of your brain.
When you take these things,
what you're capable of doing,
what bothers you,
what freaks you out,
what you don't give a shit about.
When you got all these people that are
on an Ssri,
antidepressants and anti anxiety
medication and over and over and over
again.
When they test these shooters,
they all test positive for something.
The pharmaceutical companies do not want
fucking hear about this.
They don't want to talk about this.
Phil Hartman,
my friend who got shot by his wife,
she was on Zoloft.
They got a settlement from zoloft.
The family got a settlement from zoloft
after she fucking shot him in the head
while he was sleeping.
This is,
there's a lot going on.
It's not just guns.
It is crazy that that fucked up kid
could get guns.
It is crazy to just crazy it.
The FBI went to his house two years
before,
but what can you do?
Do you hear about the kid that they just
stopped and China,
the Chinese immigrant kid,
they're sending back that his roommates
in college,
we're saying this fucking guy's
stockpile and guns.
The cops went to visit him.
He went and bought another gun and he's
talking all kinds of crazy shit and
everybody's nervous about him.
Like he's a fucking shooter,
wedded,
ready to happen.
Stop going to class.
And that's how they sent him back
because he's on a student visa.
You can't not be in class.
This kid was like gearing up.
He was gearing up and maybe,
maybe they caught it before it happened
and maybe they wouldn't have like two
years ago when they interviewed this,
uh,
the kid from Parkland now decayed.
The strangest thing about the parkland
shooting is the interview one of the
teachers did on ABC.
That's this,
this doesn't make any sense to me at
all.
It's like she said,
um,
I have the video.
I could send it to you,
Jen.
I,
it's,
it's less than a minute.
She says,
why?
I opened up,
I heard the,
I heard shots.
I opened up the door.
All the kids ran in the hid behind their
desk and there I saw the shooter 20 feet
away from me,
but at first I thought he was a
policeman.
I'm like,
what is the police doing here?
He had full body armor and mask on a
helmet on and was shooting.
I was like,
what is the cost?
What are the cops doing here?
That is the strangers,
uh,
video I've seen because possibly someone
shooting at the kid.
That's not what she said.
She said she saw the shooter.
That's right,
but I mean,
how long was she watching for?
Right?
If you're like looking out the window
and you see someone that's shooting
someone or shooting a gun or even
holding a gun,
first of all,
you have to realize that people in those
traumatic situations,
their memory is very fucked up.
It's very shaky.
Your brain's flooded with adrenaline.
You may remember your openness
suggestion.
People can put things in your head and
you all of a sudden think that that was
a real memory that you saw.
There's been like scientific studies on
that and about suggestive memory and
about someone can literally it,
especially during periods of great
duress,
they can introduce ideas into your head
and you will tell those ideas
hours later,
days later as your own and you don't
even realize that they put them in your
head.
It's real weird memory in traumatic
situations like guns,
shootouts and shit like that is haywire
because you're on,
you're working on that reptilian part of
your brain.
You're down to the lowest level.
Like my friend Steve Rinella got
attacked by a grizzly bear.
He was in a fog neck island.
It's a crazy podcast.
Heman.
These other guys,
they had killed an elk and they were
packing this elk out and they left the
elk by the tree while they were at their
camp.
Then they went to go back and a baird
claim the elk and this bear rushed him
and he was like,
the one of the ways you described to me,
it's like you have an idea in your head
of like what?
Like an animal instinct is like,
and he goes,
I'm telling you,
this goes way deeper than that.
This goes,
wait,
when you really think your life is in
danger,
you really think it's over.
You don't even exist anymore.
You're moving.
You have no idea what you're doing.
You're you're you.
You have to piece together what happened
afterwards and you were barely there in
the first place.
You're just gone.
You're gone.
You see somebody else like you have no
fucking idea who you even are right
there.
And then all these people that like I
would have run in the building kicked
that fucking guy's ass.
You barely even know who you are.
You've got this video.
Oh,
I sent you the video,
the video of that.
People have to understand memory.
Well,
let's listen to her and then let's see
if she sounds like,
okay,
let's hear what she says.
I actually sent,
sent you that the actual clips at the
one.
This is not it.
Didn't I send,
I sent you one right on your phone.
This is not it though.
That's,
that's the lady.
But I don't know when,
when she's going to say let's just play
it cause we don't hear it.
We're not hearing it,
Jamie.
That's good.
Dick Writing Love Letters.
When the fire alarm went off,
as students filed into the hallway,
she heard gun fire.
The killing had begun.
Okay.
I was about two feet away from my door.
All of a sudden I heard gunshots in the
stairwell,
which is about 20 feet away from my
room.
And then kids were screaming and then
running back towards me and towards the
end of the hallway.
So I just went in this very strange
autopilot mode where I pivoted on my
feet.
I unlocked my door and the kids just
start pouring in my room.
I don't know how many kids were in
there,
but it was pulling them and getting them
in and shouting at them to get in the
room.
And then I suddenly saw the shooter
about 20 feet from me standing at the
end of the hallway,
actively shooting down the hallway,
just a barrage of bullets.
And I'm staring at him thinking,
why is the police here?
This is strange cause he's in full metal
garb.
Helmet facemask a bulletproof armor
shooting this rifle that I've never seen
before.
Huh?
I don't know.
That sounds like a someone who saw
something.
Yeah,
very good.
Look at it.
And then there's another video of a girl
saying yeah we heard shots and we're
running through the hallway and then I
run into Nicholas crews and I looked at
him and I told him,
Mike,
isn't it weird that everyone thought
this was going to be you?
And then he just stood there and then we
ran off cause we heard more shots.
Wow.
That's th th it doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't make any sense.
And that stops those details get taken
down.
Those videos get taken to dive.
Video's not taking down.
They've been taking them down when they
find him,
they take,
there's this people actively taken down
witness testimony that doesn't go with
the official narrative man.
So you think that this is like a flag,
like someone shot up the school food all
the time.
That's what they do.
And then they focus on it.
They got it.
They got bad.
This Nicholas crews guy and they go,
oh,
we got a perfect guy.
So they come in,
they have a professional team,
they drag a nicholas crews,
they do what they gotta do.
They throw him in there,
arrest him and go,
we got him and then everyone buys it.
That's what's going on in my opinion,
in my opinion.
But this is a,
this is a crazy opinion,
right?
Because you weren't there on the other
side of the country I'm sure.
But every time there's any sort of a
mass event,
some horrible event,
there's always conspiracies,
you know,
because most these star,
they're like to have a,
what was going on right before this was
the release of the Pfizer Document and
conspiracy,
you know,
and the doctor was bearing that the
five,
the document was a document that trump
released and got zero zero air play from
mainstream media.
And it was a document that that showed
that
a lot of really important people in
government from all the agencies were
all colluding together to take down
trump.
And there's text messages and emails.
They're going back and forth.
So they all work together with
Hollywood,
with using Hollywood.
So there's this so five's,
the document was about to get dropped
and everyone was saying,
wait,
they're they,
they're backed into a corner.
They're going to pull something off.
Watch.
Here it comes.
They're going to pull out.
There's going to be up shooting or
something.
Wait for it.
Here it comes,
and then boom.
So as soon as it happened,
the reason why conspiracy theorist are
gone,
that's it.
And look at all the mistakes.
Look at,
look at all the testimony.
That doesn't make any sense that they're
ignoring like that.
The thing,
the thing that gets me is there's so
many fuck ups in that shooting as a
false flag.
We're like all these,
these witness test,
the witness testimony.
That doesn't make any sense.
That to me,
I think they did it on purpose to keep
all the conspiracy theorists busy
because there's so much shit.
It's so cheap to keep everyone away.
That doesn't make any sense to keep
everybody away from the Fi's document
documentary.
You know what?
It's also possible that people that were
at that shooting,
their memories all fucked up because
there were so many shooting people.
That's a real thing,
like that's 100% she sounded like she
didn't know what she was talking about
then since then,
but that wasn't when the shooting was
going down.
You got to see people when you see
people like right when they've seen some
shit,
their brains scrambled.
Yeah.
That's something that have to take into
consideration.
Especially some nice lady probably never
saw anybody get shot in their lives.
Probably never saw much violence.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Maybe,
I don't know.
There's two,
there's two sides of it.
There's,
there's people that believe the official
story and then there's people that see
it as,
oh,
this was the false flag to distract from
the Pfizer document lists.
I'm not saying that false flags don't
exist.
I mean you and I was discussed on this
podcast in great detail is important.
False flag,
which is operation northwoods.
Yeah.
If they're willing to do that,
they're willing to do
anything.
This is also the problem when we say
they operation northwoods was 1962.
The question is if that's how they did
business back then,
which is what they did.
I mean operation northwoods,
they were planning on attacking
Guantanamo Bay with the Cuban going to
arm Cuban friendlies,
have them attack Guantanamo Bay.
They can sacrifice American lives.
They were going to blow up a drone.
Jetliner blame it on the Cubans.
All this was to get us enthusiastic
about going to war with Cuba.
They were going to sacrifice American
lives.
This is 100%.
They were going to lie and fake shit.
Normal,
which was normal empires for all
countries is just a normal false flags
are.
It's nothing new.
It's been going on since the dawn of
time.
False flags.
That's old school.
The question is,
and this is for the rational person
who's like,
this is ridiculous.
You have to wonder,
is that evolved?
Right?
Everything evolves.
The,
the,
uh,
the way we use technology evolves,
the way we use literature evolves,
the way we use TV evolve,
everything evolves.
Does that evil corruption in government
evolved to or does it just somehow or
another get snuffed out because of the
light?
They don't buy that.
I don't,
I don't buy that.
If you look at all the different things
that we've shown that there's collusion
in,
just look at the fact that someone like
Hillary Clinton can run for president
while she was making hundreds of
thousands of dollars giving speeches to
banks,
like when she was in that debate with
Bernie Sanders and Bernie Sanders was
like released his transcripts.
Tell us what you said.
Tell us what you said to those Nice Bank
are people that give you a half a
million dollars or whatever the fuck
they gave you.
Like that's insane to think that some,
I was like,
listen dude,
she is so fucking entertaining.
We're going to give her $250,000 for an
hour.
It's worth it.
Trust me.
I know where in the banking business and
I know we make money with money.
You know what I mean?
We're all about money.
We know the value of money.
We're in the banking business.
This lady talking is worth a quarter
million dollars.
It's the best.
She's going to go up there.
She's going to knock your socks off.
So she's amazing.
She's funny.
She's hilarious.
She's amazing.
Her speech is super well and she stands
up there on the podium and just knocks
your fucking Dick into the dirt.
Was this Hillary Clinton gets
humiliating $7,000 less than snookie for
speech at rutgers as her story grows
old.
Wow.
So she got,
she got a price slash to $25,000 I think
they're kind of thrown under the bus.
Her standard fee was $200,000 per
speech,
but some folks suggested it may be her
broken record that set the recent slash
price of 25,000 she made so much money
off the Clinton Foundation.
She's fine.
She's like,
I'll do it for a thousand did I got
fucking 100 million from that Haiti
earthquake?
Are you getting the but those people,
people like her.
I think one of the things in the back of
their head is always the potential
litigation.
I think they're always want to stockpile
legal funds cause someone could always
come after them.
If you stop and think about the Clinton
Foundation and like,
you know,
if you had 100 million and now
you have,
you know,
75 million,
you're like,
oh my God,
we gotta I gotta take some odd jobs that
shit.
Do some speeches and Saudi Arabia,
listen,
it should be illegal for someone to run
for president.
If someone who they could influence in a
positive way with passing things and
signing legislature,
if you pushing things forward using
their influence,
if someone is in a position that they
could do that for a company and that
company wants him keeping you $200,000
to talk,
that's just fucking insane.
That's insane.
That's bribery.
That's are you saying that it's worth
$200,000 if she sucked every dick in the
room,
it wouldn't be worth $200,000 right.
There's no way.
Who's going to pay $1,000 for a Hillary
Clinton Bro job other than for the
story.
I think she didn't get a lot of money
for blow job.
Do you think so?
I think fucking alt right guys.
A disparate fucking battle on down dude
than Devin Bu cockies.
You know what I mean?
She'll do do a bit cocky for getting
this.
I feel this feels like a disrespectful
term we're taking with Hillary.
I'm sorry.
As a person,
forget about it.
As a woman,
just as a politician,
no one should be,
it should just be impossible.
There's enough spirasi theory that,
uh,
Hillary Clinton's father,
he wrote him,
I,
I'm assuming he's,
he's not alive anymore,
was a huge Jewish mob boss who is
responsible for
opium going into Chicago.
I don't know if that's real,
but it makes sense to me.
It look what we know for a fact that
some politicians have run drugs before
the bushes.
But here's the biggest one.
The fucking Kennedy's open,
open,
flat out.
I mean,
it was moonshine at the time.
But guess what?
That's drugs.
That's as much of a drug worse than
wheat.
It's worse.
Way Worse.
I mean that this how the Kennedy family
made their money.
We needed a president to run marijuana.
How cool would that have Tommy Chong for
president,
Jimmy Carter was like,
he was just doing,
he just stuck to marijuana drug.
John for President Tom,
he's got,
he's got diversity on his side.
Cheech could be the running main cheech
and Chong,
2020 guys get on it.
I have you on the podcast support you
100%.
If you think about all the stuff the
government was willing to do over over
time,
like,
you know,
uh,
operation northwoods for instance.
Uh,
they were willing to kill their own
people.
Uh,
um,
you know,
there's a lot of corruption,
bribery,
lot of shit in the government.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
If you had to equate that to one person,
you could say the u s government is kind
of like John Gotti.
Right,
right,
right.
Kinda right.
And you're a little bit,
a little bit,
I killed some people.
Yeah,
for sure.
It's on people.
If they cross him off boss.
A lot of,
yeah,
a lot of scamming going on,
a lot of stealing.
He's Kinda,
he's Kinda like a politician.
He's kind of like the overall,
you know,
how could anybody trust anything?
He would say.
Yeah.
And anytime someone would say,
hey dude,
like some John Gotti nerd came up,
he goes,
dude,
you know,
he killed 15 people one night in my
annual,
you wouldn't did,
where's the proof?
Where's the proof?
Show me.
He wouldn't say that you would go,
you believe in.
And even if it wasn't true,
he's like,
[inaudible] still a douchebag.
He's still a criminal.
He's still killing people.
So yeah,
you were wrong about that.
I was actually,
you know,
traffic content and it wasn't,
but still,
you know what I mean?
People just naturally,
when it comes to the government,
they know how corrupt they are.
They know that they're willing to kill
their own people.
They know that the politicians aren't
waking up going,
how am I going to make everyone's lives
better?
So all those speeches you here,
you know them trying to like hell.
They're not thinking about helping their
thinking about keeping,
keeping their power.
They're the criminals.
That's what's going on.
So while they're in a business and this
business has criminal rules,
they've allowed them to have these
criminal rules.
It's all about how can every politician,
they're all trying to get ahold of that.
That tax money.
Oh,
that's the,
the,
the end game right there.
You get that tax money.
You're never,
you could steal tax money and people
were never going to come after you.
You Steel Corporation money,
you're going to die.
I didn't even get mad if he still tax
and the tax man,
this has just come up with the bills.
Come up with something.
Anything.
Just anything.
Okay.
Uh,
W W we this bills to,
to build a churches and uh,
we're going to help children around the
world and we're going to find a cure for
leukemia and that.
Fuck,
yeah,
cool.
Boom.
It's really easy.
You just gotta make up some shit.
You got to pretend that you're going to
help people.
Oh,
this one's the affordable housing act.
You know,
we can help more people like that.
Politicians really trying to help with,
they're trying to do is rip off tax
money.
That's it.
It's all allocated.
Move it,
move it to the people that they wanted
to have it too.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a dirty business.
I'm open to it.
Then it changes and the seagulls.
I,
I think the way we are being programmed
in doctrinated,
I think it's genius.
It's working so God damn well because it
works on really smart people.
There's intelligent people all over the
guys.
Damn.
We're invested in the system.
They,
everybody's invested in this
indoctrination that the school system
man,
you know,
school really is designed to get your,
take the kids from the family,
like the kids believe their teachers
more than their own parents and they,
it that the state takes your kid.
They're there.
They're raising their kids.
Yeah.
It's,
it's ridiculous,
man.
I think most of what's going on in
schools is not that.
I think most of it is people that are
just totally apathetic about teaching
people.
They don't give a fuck.
Most of these people that are teaching,
they're doing it as a job.
There's a lot of terrible fucking
teachers out there and they don't get
paid anything.
And it's 30 conspiracy taught,
not taught.
And told how to teach and what to show.
They're not like,
okay,
just give us your own versions of
English together with educators,
they get together to try to figure out a
way to get people to learn these things,
but it's uninspired.
That's more,
more than anything.
There's no money to a conspiracy theory
is that the Rockefeller,
John Rockefeller and Carnegie designed
the school system to slaves and to
separate the family.
What's the conspirators career?
The conspiracy theories they designed to
create workers,
right?
People that are slaves to the system.
The conspiracy theories,
they openly said,
we don't,
we don't need any more philosophers are
geniuses.
We got an offer that we,
we,
we got that and we got science right
here.
We've got jenny sites.
You need come to us like w when was the
last,
what was the last science?
Great scientific discovery like in the
last 40 years that wasn't government
funded.
Like there's,
there's no what their,
who's funding these studies.
Why do you think that they're government
funded?
Like some new shit they come out with?
Uh,
I don't know.
See,
Yeah,
I don't know.
No one can name anything.
I don't know what.
I mean,
we'd have to go over some of the styles,
but I'm sure a lot of them are not
government.
I'm assuming that most scientists are
getting paychecks from the government.
I'm just assuming that I'm just,
I'm,
I'm assuming that most scientific datas
is not,
it's coming from a bunch of scientists
who
are getting grants and they can't say
crazy shit.
They got it.
And there,
you know,
I sent you that one email that one guy
was telling me that there,
uh,
he worked for a team of scientists and
they're working for pesticide company
and they're told to the go,
we're going to do some studies here and
we want it to look like this and let's
keep doing it.
Keep doing the studies until when we
got,
oh,
that's the worst they can do.
That is insane.
That's insane.
They keep doing study until they get the
results they want and then they don't
publish the bad studies.
The only published the good studies and
this is what you have done.
It seems like there's basically in a
nutshell,
like three kinds of science.
There's,
there's the sign like pseudoscience.
It's like it's pretend science,
but for sure it's not real.
It's false science.
Pseudo science and then there's the
scientific facts like for sure
[inaudible] it's a scientific fact that
I can get on the Internet with my
iphone.
I don't need to read a study about it
and say,
oh,
I didn't.
I actually can.
I know it.
My friends know it.
That's a scientific fact and other
scientific is my car will take me to
point a to point B to point c over and
over and it may break down every now and
then.
That's a fact.
That's us.
The science of my car.
I believe that science,
scientific facts and then there's a
science that you,
you,
you have to take the scientist's word
for it because there's no way that you
can verify that if you have to take,
do you have to have faith in science?
That's like a religion.
But scientism,
hold on a second.
What are you talking about?
Like what particular kind of,
any kind of science,
whether it's a medical science,
if you,
you have,
you have a choice to believe in science
that you can't verify yourself.
You could believe it you,
but you'll have to believe it.
You could say experts in the field
verify it.
All the people that understood all the
bop with all the,
we,
all the science that we know that though
had been,
has been corrupted.
Just the big ones.
Uh,
sugar science,
uh,
tobacco science,
marijuana science,
vaccine signs.
We know for sure all just those four
that there's been a lot of corruption
and so it's hard to trust.
So when someone comes out and especially
the government and NGOs,
yeah,
our scientists,
scientists say that it's safe
and effective.
You got to be like,
damn,
I don't know about that.
I'm not going to just take your fucking
word for it.
You know what I mean?
You guys are criminals.
You're John Gotti and you guys are
saying,
you guys are saying that this is safe
and effective.
I don't know about that.
You know,
maybe it is.
I hope it is,
but I don't know.
I don't know cause they can't prove it
for myself.
Oftentimes drugs that get past as being
safe and they turn out to not be exactly
the problem with these studies.
Exactly.
This is like when we were talking about
earlier with that,
nobody wants to discuss the idea that
psychotropic drugs have played a part in
school shootings.
The salt,
a very recent thing with human beings,
the reason spike,
but they're talking about the recent
spike in shootings,
even wet by people they know we're mass
shooters.
Those people are almost all on these
pills,
but this,
these pills are very recently big.
So when you're talking about,
yeah,
so when you're talking about just the
history of human beings involved in mass
killings,
it's really recent.
Craze is ramping up.
It's going crazy.
Yeah.
Well you know what also is ramping up
people taking pills.
Yeah.
These things are somehow,
are they?
They might not be the cause of it.
100% it might be society,
it might be suppression,
it might be terrible childhood rearing.
It might be childhood abuse in might be
all sorts of like mental health issues
that are inherited.
All sorts of crazy diseases that people
inherit mental diseases.
Even the vaccine pamphlets.
There's I think that HPV vaccine that
like girls are taking it at 10 11 and 12
man,
that the shit that it says in the past,
but there's not just one to one site.
Possible side effect is suicidal
thoughts wanting to,
it's called an one,
it's called impending doom.
What's up?
Take your pills last night.
That documentary on Netflix that's been
going around.
How is it?
It's pretty good.
There's not a lot,
a lot.
A lot of the adderall one isn't.
It is,
it is,
yeah.
So there's not a lot of information we
don't already know.
I feel like they just kind of compile it
and make it look really good.
But one interesting thing that you'd
like,
he just brought up.
A doctor says in it,
there's no side effects to pills.
There's just unintended benefits or non
benefits that you want.
They're all affects.
There's no like side effect of like
diarrhea for instance.
It's an effect of the pill.
Just wasn't what you wanted.
I see what you're saying.
Don't call it the side effect.
An effect.
Right.
So if he takes something and on some
people it gives suicidal thoughts.
It's not a side effect.
It's just an effect of taking that to
those people.
There's,
there's girls wanting to kill themselves
for taking the HPV.
That's his dad for taking acne
medication.
Accutane is a big that one.
Oh,
do you know Andrew Santino?
Hilarious comedian.
Funny Mother Fucker.
He took acutane when he was saying high
school.
Is that what he said?
Said it was like the best thing that
ever happened to him because his face
totally cleared up.
But the worst thing that ever happened
to him in terms of like how it made them
feel like,
it just,
it makes me feel a lot of people get it
and they get suicidal thoughts.
Yeah,
for sure.
See.
So you got to ask yourself,
you know,
even if,
whether,
whether whether kids really are shooting
up schools or it's a false flag in there
setting up the kids to
do it with.
That's the other side.
Whatever the,
whatever the,
the truth is there.
There's a gigantic problem with these
pills that are making people crazy and
no one really,
this is not a big push to stop it or
anything.
They're being protected there being
retired.
There's a giant business in it.
There's billions of dollars.
Sure.
But there's also a lot of people that
liked those pills.
There's a lot of people that loves
xanax.
Like this is,
again,
this is one of those things where we
always want to look at the bad side of
it.
A lot of people love crack to crack
person.
You could get thrown in jail for that.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
But I mean people that are functional
people just how you like weed.
I like weed.
Some people like Xanax.
I'm not saying you can't have that.
It's not my opinion.
It's not,
it's not,
that's not how I feel.
What I am saying is like we need to be
honest about the consequences of all
these things and that this is somehow or
another left out of the equation when I
think it's a major part of the equation.
I don't think it's the only reason why
people are shooting up schools or any of
this shit,
but I think it absolutely must be
playing a factor and for whatever reason
people don't want to consider that
factor.
And I think some of it is because
there's a lot of people out there who
liked those pills.
They liked the way they feel on
antidepressants.
They liked the way they feel on anti
anxiety medication.
They like take an ambien before they go
to bed.
They don't want to hear.
They like what it gives them.
I know people who can't sleep without
ambient,
they can't sleep without it.
If you tried telling them that Ambien
fucks up your heart rate or does this to
that or you know,
make up some things.
I don't know if it fucks up your heart
and just saying that if you started
saying that to people they would,
they would just immediately tune out
whatever dude,
I'm sleeping like a baby.
You know,
it'd be a great false flag is if they
set up another shooter and just said he
was totally stoned,
you know,
that way they could reversely because of
course nobody would buy the legalization
of weed of course to choke.
Do you know what?
Uh,
I,
um,
what would I started smoking then
changed my mind.
They have the power in the media,
ted,
to turn it into that.
Like all of a sudden these guys are
getting really high in Colorado and in
California we need it.
We need a,
it's a joke.
It's not funny.
I wouldn't work today.
I've been smoking blunts and I would
like,
I smoked him.
I was like,
okay,
now I understand rap music.
Like I was like,
these rappers are so aggressive,
but they're also high.
I'm like,
what the fuck's going on?
It's the God damn tobacco tobacco mixed
in with weed.
That is a different thing.
That's a different animal.
It's a little too potent.
Sometimes it's a little too woo.
It's like you're like,
you're like,
what are we talking about?
I like it every now and then.
Every now and then I like to,
I like,
and I'm like,
you know what gives you a different kind
of head buzz?
Well,
tobacco things,
yet I donald's her own,
he got me under dip when he was not a
not,
I haven't done it since then,
but when we were in the podcast,
he did it.
I swallowed some of it and uh,
but one thing I liked about it,
I was like,
oh,
now I get why you guys do it.
It's like,
it hypes you up.
It gets you kind of like elevated,
you know?
It's like you ever smoke a cigar?
Maybe too.
It's a version of a cigarette.
Like you're getting your time,
some serious fucking nicotine.
Your system.
When you smoke a fat Stokey,
you've got a big old fucking Hoyle de
Monterrey double corona and you're put
out castle style.
By the time you get to the end of that
thing,
your highest fuck dude.
You're not high like you can't talk or
like you can't walk or you can't
function,
but you're definitely feeling that
tobacco,
you're feel it's,
it's doing something to your system and
they say it actually has a cognitive
enhancing function that's similar to
nootropics and coffee as well that are
like it.
It actually can make you perform better
on tests if you smoked cigarettes or if
you smoke a cigar and writers always say
that like I know a lot of people who
write like writers for sitcoms and stuff
like that.
Those guys always smoked cigarettes when
they write and they say they can't write
without smoking.
Steven King said that it's like their
weed.
Yeah,
well it,
it does have something going on men,
but it's instead of like,
it's not,
it's to me it's more like amped than it
is creative.
We'd is super creative.
Weed makes me think of thoughts while I
write them down on my,
I can't even claim that.
That's not even my thought,
but that's weeds thought.
You know what I mean?
Like I would have never just leave me by
myself with no drugs in a,
in a notebook.
I would've never come up with that idea.
But the weeds like,
hey man,
listen to this.
You know,
the weed weed is way more of a,
uh,
like an idea steroid.
I believe it,
dude.
I see people who don't smoke weed and
they write and I'm like,
cool,
you're so brave
out there out there with no helmet.
You got no life preserver on.
And now it's crazy legal everywhere.
This amazing,
this recreational weed in California.
It's insane.
He just walked nine states now.
Yeah.
Crazy.
I think 18 states have league,
a legal medical and nine states have
legal,
recreational,
nice.
Two-Cents mass.
Yeah.
It's a wave.
It's going across the whole country.
It's changing everything and it's good.
And you know what the next wave is?
MTMA MTMA therapy for PTSD patients has
unprecedented results.
Maps is involved in this.
What does it,
multiple [inaudible] Multiple
Disciplinary Association for Psychedelic
studies or something like that.
Maps is amazing.
A really above board organization that,
um,
is at the forefront of legalization of
psychedelics and of psychedelic research
and they've been involved in studies
with soldiers and they have amazing
results with this stuff.
Mtma just lets you forgive yourself and
lets you forget everything.
It reprograms your brain had reprogram,
lets you forgive other people in your
life.
It changes.
It could.
One hit of MDM,
MDM and Dma,
I that always confuses me,
molly and said it's a lot easier.
One hit can change your taste in music
for ever,
for ever.
I believe it because before he ever did
it,
the first time I did it was 1997
and before that I was a dj at this point
and I couldn't stand techno.
I hated techno music so much and I was a
dj and anytime a girl went on stage and
she was a technocrat,
I'm like,
this is because I played drums for real.
So when you listen to techno or house,
it's like that's the most basic dump
chute.
Every song,
every fucking drum beat to Sam.
I couldn't accept it as a musician.
And most musicians feel that way about
tech now.
And um,
I went to a birthday party at the key
club in Hollywood and I walk in and
upstairs is techno and downstairs in the
little bottom club is hip hop and it was
a birthday party and everyone was
downstairs.
And me and my buddy rick,
we walk in and we're standing at the
edge of the techno floyd and there's
like all these dudes just like dancing
by themselves or just like mental cases,
right.
And I was just standing there looking at
him going,
what the fuck is wrong with these
people?
Oh my God.
So I went downstairs or playing hip hop
and like,
that's what I want to hear it at clubs.
I want to hear hip hop at a club,
I want to dance with a girl,
not by myself,
you know,
so I'm downstairs and then they start
passing around some molly.
And so say we want to do,
and I'll never forget that that first
one was blue.
I'm like,
I dunno,
I dunno.
So I took it.
Me and my buddy both took it and it hit
us that that first hit just hits you
like a fucking pile of bricks.
We go upstairs and we're on the dance or
dancing like morons,
dude,
and we're looking at each other.
Go,
you get it.
I get it.
I go,
you'll get it.
I get it.
From that point on,
you got all into Trent's?
Yeah.
From that point,
it wasn't just like that night.
It changed my musical taste right in one
hit and I had a friend at the club,
it was a total rnb duty,
hate a techno,
and he would talk shit.
When I play tech and I got one day,
you're going to do some modeling and
you're going to be all into technical.
It's a fuck you.
That will never happen.
I can't stand this music.
He starts dating the raver check like
six months later at the club,
some raver chick,
he ends up at a ray.
He ends up dropping some molly,
he starts coming in and bringing all
these new tech note cds and he's all
into full blown in the transit tech.
No,
just one hint.
This is the real,
real
problem.
It's illegal,
so when you get it from someone,
you don't know what the fuck you're
getting.
That's the real problem with molly.
This is a real problem with Mtma.
It's also the dosage.
You don't know what the dosage is
supposed to be.
Look,
you can overdose on alcohol and
alcohol's everywhere,
but everybody knows what the dose of
alcohol is was.
You go to a bar and you get a shot of
Jack Daniels.
You know what that is?
It's not like sometimes you get a shot
of Dac,
Jen,
Jack Daniels in his Jack Daniels.
Sometimes you get it in,
it's super fucking moonshine is 10 times
stronger and you die.
That's the problem with heroin.
Yes.
The problem with a lot of things,
the real problem with Mtma seems to be
that it's illegal.
That's the real problem and what they're
finding is that there's great benefits
if it's used correctly.
I mean,
anything can be abused,
but that doesn't mean we should make it
illegal and what they want to do.
I think their,
their timeline is somewhere around 2021
making it legal for,
for therapy.
It's going to change the world.
It's going to change everything.
It's gonna change the way people feel
about the past is going to change the
way people interact with each other.
You're going to know just by people's
behavior whether or not they've ever
done it right.
You know where it comes from,
where MTMA comes from?
Well that's the part of it.
The act of ingredient that takes you a,
that just plant,
right?
Where's that plan at the of Thailand.
Crazy wars over Thailand or
Cambodia in Cambodia.
It's like the bark,
like the,
something about the like the root of a
tree trunk or something.
Yeah.
So it has something to do with a tree,
James pulling it up,
but it becomes very dangerous for those
people.
Right?
Like all that the trafficking becomes
crazies.
Yeah.
They fuck up for us.
Like for us being chopped down of just,
just for the people being murdered.
It's like,
it's heavy duty stuff.
Sassafras.
Um,
I dunno,
I googled it and just look at images and
that's what's popping up.
Maybe it was a place Mtma Cambodia
trees.
Bars.
Sassafras.
Okay.
Maybe that is Sassafras and SEF.
Rolly Sassafras.
Yeah,
I guess it Sassafras Dude.
It's a whatever,
whatever that plan is.
They take the see if that just google
vice,
uh,
the making of ecstasy,
cause I'm pretty sure vice to this.
But could you go with that please?
I think a vice had a special on that.
I wonder what would happen if he just
ate it raw.
I wonder,
can you do that?
Okay.
Um,
is there a special,
what does it say?
The truth about ecstasy?
Yeah.
So there's,
there's some sort of a vice episode
where they grow this stuff anyway.
Um,
this should be something that's not
distributed by criminals were in ski
masks like you've seen in this video
should be something distributed by
stores and they should be doctors.
And if you wanted it,
you could have a rave where you even
have medical centers in the rave.
We keep people from overdosing the
transitionary period from people going
from drugs being totally illegal to some
drugs,
having massive benefits.
Like if you're,
you go to a club,
right?
And everyone,
there's,
c'mon,
we're doing shots,
were doing shots,
the whole fucking bars getting wasted
and drunk.
Everybody's fine with that.
But you're not fine with a club where
everybody does a small amount of
ecstasy.
Well,
why can't you do that?
that's drugs.
Well,
the other one's drugs too.
He just used to those drugs.
Once we get past that hurdle,
and it might take a whole generation
before people get used to places where
you can go,
one drug gets you violent,
one drug makes you want to have sex.
So listen,
you're not going to stop that drug.
Here's my point.
It's a powerful,
really useful drug.
People going to find out about it.
It's an amazing experience.
They're going to do it.
So what's the best way to handle that?
Best way to handle is make it safe,
make it legal,
make it regulated so they know what
actually is in each one of these fucking
pills.
You're not getting it from some pimp or
some asshole or some fucking crazy dude
is stuffed in a balloon.
Put it up his ass hole and made it
across the border with it.
You don't know where the fuck you're
getting this stuff.
All sorts of shit.
Amphetamines and all sorts of crazy
shit.
And people die from it because they
don't know what the fuck is in there.
Here it is.
Yeah.
Um,
okay.
It says more a boy,
Mr Mode a h p.
R e w p.
H n.
O.
M.
Trees.
Murray proved pericom trees in Cambodia
and the,
they're found in Cambodia's Oh,
Sassafras.
The factory has been set up to distill,
sacrificed oil,
uh,
processed by boiling the roots and the
trunk of the exceptionally rare plant.
Oh,
they're really rare trees to wow.
How crazy is that?
How many of these fucking trees or like
in the middle of the rain forest and we
don't know about,
you know,
I mean,
there's some,
there's gotta be some shit where they
haven't tapped into it yet.
They're finding all sorts of different
pharmaceutical drugs that they can
cocked out of stuff.
The transplants,
they buy Amazon.
Yeah.
They find all the
insects are evolving so fast and the
Amazon that they only have names for I
think 90% 10% of the insects,
90% they have no names.
No,
it's crazy.
Is that true?
They have all sorts of bugs and the
Amazon for sure that they have an
identified,
they know that for a fact and they do
evolve.
They're rare thing where you can,
there's like some primitive life forms
that you could find that didn't exist
before.
Like they found this crayfish,
I think it's in India or Europe,
maybe Europe,
crayfish that produces by cloning.
They don't have sex.
So female,
they're all female and one crayfish just
makes a bunch of other babies.
It just makes babies just need sex.
And they're like,
what the fuck?
I mean obviously there's no genetic
diversity.
Right.
Cause they obviously would need a male
DNA.
It makes it the female DNA.
There it is.
Mute and crayfish clones itself and it's
taking over Europe.
So this crayfish doesn't fuck,
they just reproduce like one crayfish
could just reproduce.
It's really bananas.
So this is a new thing that didn't exist
25 years ago.
This is something that they're very sure
wasn't a,
a living organism up until recently.
Here's the good thing.
Crayfish are delicious.
People are starving to death.
Now they've got some mother fuckers that
all you have to do is just throw some
stuff in there.
You don't have to count on them.
Fucking,
maybe it's the same stuff that made the
frogs gay.
Could be,
could be bro.
Maybe it's linked.
Could be,
but if you,
I mean it could be,
could be pesticides,
it could be.
Um,
look,
there's another thing about the amount
of people that flush pills down the
toilet and how much that shit goes to
water treatment plants and into,
um,
aqueducts and reservoirs and shit.
Yeah.
There's a lot of pills that get flushed
down our toilets and some of them make
it into rivers and shit.
Some of them making it to the ocean.
You know what's supposed to be
particularly bad.
I never thought about this until a
friend of mine who was a surfer told me
he was a yoga teacher,
was a surfer and said nobody told him
and he got real sick cause he went into
the ocean right after the rain.
You can't go to the ocean after the rain
because when it rains in La,
all that bullshit,
all the chemicals and toxins and
cleaners and oil and gasoline and
plastic washes into the water like right
at the shore.
And that's where it's all just swashing
around in there with the waves and you
get in there and you get sick as fuck.
You're basically getting poisoned.
Is there some kind of filtration system
before they just let all the water just
run right and right is right from the
streets,
from the runoff just from the streets.
I think it,
where does the toilet water go?
Does that water goes through a sewage
system that goes through a sanitation
system.
But sometimes those break,
I was uh,
at the Charles River in Boston once and
it was a,
it was like right across the street from
where I lived and I'd hang out there all
the time when I was a kid and I was
standing there on the shore and I saw
these bubbles and like these chunks of
things floating up to the water.
And I was like,
what the fuck is that?
And then I saw condom bloke come up and
I went,
ah,
that's a sewer pipe death,
flushing condoms and like shit and
condom water.
It's coming right through the fucking
ground into this river where all these
fish lift,
these fish are probably living off a
human shit.
What's the water like after the s the
sewage water runs through the filtration
system.
What does that water perfect and where
does it go?
Fiji puddles that does it go into 99 to
99 for eight ounces.
Based on what I saw online,
it seems like Fiji water is the best
water out there.
Like they took,
they tested a lot of bottled water and,
and a lot of bottled water has a lot of
bullshit in it.
Look at this.
After 50 years,
Boston's Charles River just became
swimmable again.
Took $500 million in nearly two decades
of work.
Here's how the city did it.
That's it,
man.
That was the river that's connected to
over that river.
Went all the way down near my house.
Why would you say the polluted people
are gross?
Well,
dude,
when and people started building shit in
the 18 hundreds it didn't give a fuck
about the future.
They took that sewer pipe and just lay
it right there,
pop it right into the fucking ocean.
I'm gonna take a shit right in that
water.
It's going to go shooting down at pipe
and drop right in a fish's head.
Who Cares?
They didn't give a fuck when they were
building things.
They would have all their industrial
runoff just go right into rivers.
They taught,
they polluted thousands of rivers.
Like who the fuck knows how many fish
died?
Because people in the early days of the
industrial revolution were fucking
assholes.
They didn't have any consequences.
They didn't,
they didn't think about the possibility
of completely destroying the
environment.
Like that didn't exist before the age of
the industrial machines.
The only time it existed before that was
in dead bodies would,
would pollute rivers systems after war.
You know,
like when people would throw bodies into
rivers like that would,
you know,
that would fuck up people's wells that
would fuck up.
Uh,
you know,
any drinking.
What people got real sick.
How did king's Shit,
well,
what did their toilets look like?
Like back in the 1,516 it was like some
dude
the his mouth.
Yeah,
you're exactly right.
I don't have shit right.
Dab Pimp ass toilets for the kings back
in the day.
I'm sure they did.
Once you google it,
Jamie Google's toilet toilet from King
Henry the eighth that King Henry the go
killed all his wives,
right?
Toilets from all the way back in the
bcs.
But I'm going to go to more resemble
King Henry.
A's got tired of those ladies just cut
their fucking heads off.
A king's loaf go to.
Where does it lead to?
Suspected by by doctors.
They want to make sure it's got enough
fiber in his diet.
Keep His highness alive.
Where did the changes?
She would just find Jamie,
what's that face called?
A thunder mug.
Oh,
nice.
Pull that up.
Here we go.
Hold on.
Make sure.
Oh,
okay.
This is a for the 16 hundreds that's
what he shit into.
That's why I say is this is a
shakespearian chamber pot,
not the bards own thunder Mug,
but it is a typical chamber pot and
that's what they would call them chamber
pots.
So it's a potty shit in like literally
shit in a pot that looks sturdy.
The,
so it's really like a toilet bowl.
It's like a toilet bowl.
It just doesn't have water in it.
Do you think they've left water in it to
make it easier to clean up next to it?
Probably smarter to have water in there.
So you plop in the water?
Yeah.
Otherwise you get a couple of slaves and
pull it out.
Dumping your good luck.
If you ever have to take a shit on a
plane and you see how little water there
is and that little thing that you drop
in logs into,
and then when you flush it never gets it
all,
you know,
and you've got to think,
do I just like play stupid and get Outta
here?
I gotta give a courtesy flush.
American revolution is a hole in the
ground.
Nice magic fallen into that hole.
That's your death.
You choked to death on shit.
It's happened.
100% happen.
Tapping,
I read about a dude who fell into a
septic tank.
The felony has septic tank and drown had
a septic tank in his backyard and he was
fixing it somehow or another and it
broke a fell through and he dragged in a
fucking septic tank.
How did they get rid of their shit in
the city?
Just regular peasants.
Like what did they just around in the
streets or did they have to collect it
and drag it out to the woods to,
good question.
Well,
there was a real issue,
uh,
in Rome in the early days of people
shitting in the streets.
And apparently there's a lot of people
in San Francisco right now that a
shitting in the streets.
It's a real issue.
Jake shields,
my friend,
uh,
the MMA fighter,
um,
Jujitsu master,
jake shields,
you know,
of course he put a video up on instagram
of some dudes shitting,
like pulling his pants down and like
shitting right into the street.
Like you said,
it's happening everywhere.
San Francisco has done an amazing amount
of bombs.
I think it was jake shields.
I don't want to speak out of turn.
Pretty sure it was just the best city
for homeless people for sure.
They let people do whatever the fuck
they want and that city,
there's so nice.
It's so open minded and they feel so
guilty because they made $1 billion from
like brazzers.com or some shit,
you know,
they take the bait,
all that tech money,
you know,
like it's different kind of
money there.
They're so liberal in comparison to like
Wall Street banker type dudes.
Those dudes are like cut throat,
right wing,
like private jet.
Fuck you Minko big watch.
Go cow,
cow doing coke.
Whereas the money on the other side,
like the tech money,
they're all like,
well diversity is really important.
And,
and women,
they need to be represented in tech and
this is their space.
This is the space for them to,
we need to let them know,
we need to encourage that.
Like there's so left way,
if they're like these homeless people,
they also be,
just because they don't have an address
doesn't mean this city is not equally.
There's,
you know,
we have to help them and offer aid
crackheads just taking diarrhea,
splatter shifts against walls.
I think they just let these people get
away with,
they were fucking mentally ill people
and they just let them wander around
through their streets cause they really
cared.
You know what they would do,
they would,
uh,
really put some money into taking care
of these people.
So just letting them wander around the
streets,
shitting all over the place.
Have a place where you can get them
clothes from the salvation army or
something like that.
Have a place where you'd give him
regular showers,
have something that's like appealing
they can go to all the time.
So you keep them from just shitting on
the streets in front of everybody.
Like that's crazy.
Billy Corgan had a residency in San
Francisco of up maybe eight years ago
and uh,
it was all about him just writing songs
on the spot and then going on stage that
night and doing brand new songs.
I could weird kind of residency.
And he had this one song that he wrote
about,
he just hanging out in the park in San
Francisco and just wrote about the bums
and how disgusting it all was and called
the song peace and love.
Excellent song.
One of his greatest songs.
It's deep.
It's about the bums.
There's so many men.
We used to run into him all the time.
When we did gigs in San Francisco,
we'd go out to eat and you'd have to do
like this bomb obstacle course on the
way to the restaurant.
Oh,
here comes wanting to get across the
street.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I don't have any money,
bro.
They're super aggressive tests.
Yes.
People were real tolerant there.
Yeah,
but isn't that better?
That's better than the opposite.
It's better.
That's,
I think it's good to live in a place
that this tolerance as possible.
Even if the super lefties get annoying,
you don't want the opposite to see they
might fuck up because there's the same
sort of mentality that goes on with
people on the far left and people on the
far right and that mentality is my way's
the right way.
I'm right.
You're wrong.
Fuck you.
I'm going to make you change.
I'm going to make you do what and that
doesn't work.
That doesn't work on anybody,
but I always feel like it's safer and
better when that's happening towards
like kindness and compassion and income
equality and all these things that are,
I see like even though it gets very
authoritarian,
I see that at least it has like a good
heart to it all.
Like even if it's misguided,
some of it's missing,
some is misguided or even if they're
pretending did,
there's always that.
That's a good move.
Right?
If you're going to pretend you pretend
towards the left,
yeah,
she was some money.
Yeah,
you could steal all sorts of tax money.
Just pretend.
Yeah,
you're helping people.
There's definitely a lot of that going
on.
There's no doubt about that.
Dude.
We haven't talked about Tony Ferguson.
It's two o'clock.
Yeah,
this is the kind of just walk already.
Holy Shit.
We ramble down.
Um,
we have to talk about Tony Ferguson,
seeing as how you,
his Jujitsu coach.
And I was fucking convinced.
I told Jamie,
I told Jimmy Smith,
I'm like,
I'm not buying it.
It's April fools.
The Shit's coming on April fools.
Fuck you man.
Yo fool me once.
Shame on you fool me 50 times or how
many times have been busted by April
fools?
Mike,
There's no fucking way.
Tony Ferguson got hurt a week before the
fight.
There's no way.
Yeah,
and it's true.
That's the first thing I thought.
I'm like,
oh my God,
everyone's going to think this is April
fools.
This Dana says,
yeah,
everyone's,
no one's going to believe this.
Can I found out,
uh,
late Saturday night,
you know,
I'm in the studio with Danny loan or
just making some music and,
um,
you know,
I knew something,
something might have been wrong because
we were supposed to work Saturday
afternoon and,
um,
he never no shows.
He's late a lot,
but he was late and I'm just hanging out
in front of a studio.
He's got his own gym now and after
awhile he didn't return his tax.
I'm like something,
you know,
he's,
he's a fucking superstar.
There's a lot of shit going on inside.
You said,
okay,
fuck it is,
I laughed and went on with my day,
went in the studio and then I get the
tax.
I can 11,
25 at night,
Saturday night.
He said,
I fucked up.
I fucked up my knee.
Uh,
blew my fucking alcl out.
Um,
he wants to fight,
he wants to fight.
He does not,
he did not,
not want to fight,
but his doctor said,
you can't fight.
And he was like,
I need a second opinion.
So he went to the UFC doctors and they
said,
nope,
you can't fight his lcls detached from
his knee according to,
so it's pulled from the bone.
It's pulled off the boat.
Yeah,
that's what they said.
It's really,
it's,
it's not like usually you tell Dana
described it.
Yeah.
Usually you tear your lcl,
MCL usually cause I've,
I've done my mcl before.
It repairs on its own so thick according
to what the doctors tell me.
I don't know shit,
but they're uh,
you know,
but you need to tell your meniscus.
You probably need surgery for that or
you tear your acl,
you for sure need surgery for that.
Um,
if it's,
if it's a complete terror,
but the lcl and the MCL,
the only time there they,
again,
according to what I hear,
the only time we need surgery is if it's
fucking blown the fuck out.
Like motorcycle acts,
acts freak things and uh,
okay.
When I say Tony wanted to fight,
he,
he would have fought with that shit.
He didn't give a fuck.
They wouldn't let him fight.
He wanted a fight.
Was He walking with sunglasses on?
Indoors?
I don't know.
I don't know what he was wearing.
This is what Dana,
Dana was saying.
I think said he,
he tripped over some wires.
Some,
you know those,
those thick cables that they lay down.
Yeah.
Apparently tripped over the water and
fell.
Fuck,
fuck.
That's insane.
It's the craziest thing ever.
It's insane.
It's so crazy.
It's so sad that fight.
It's doomed.
Dana White said he would never put that
fight on again.
I'm like,
are you crazy?
Book that Shit again.
The thing that sucks is the thing that
sucks is a four is a magic number.
Dana said in an interview,
kind of hinted at or alluded to the fact
May,
I hope I'm wrong,
but that they would,
they're going to strip tony of his
interim belt like,
you know Robert Whitaker's.
Where'd you see that?
Um,
someone told me I didn't hear it,
so that's why I'm saying,
I don't know if it's true.
Someone said,
yeah,
David,
he just did an interview and he,
he was,
he was a hinton like oil.
He said it and sell it in such a way
that Tony is going to get stripped of
his belt.
And I,
and I thought,
that's ridiculous.
Here's my question.
If someone is the champ,
right,
and they get injured and they can't
defend their title,
then they have an interim title.
Right?
But if the interim guy gets injured and
can't defend the interim title,
do they strip the end?
Is that ever happened?
Robert Whittaker,
he loses interim lightweight title when
number grumet often hallway square off.
So I guess they're taking the time.
They didn't do that.
I mean,
they didn't do that to Robert Whitaker.
He was the interim interim champion.
Should they have an interim interim?
No,
I dunno man.
But um,
it doesn't seem like they let the
whitaker take 11 months off to recover.
Why would they do the exact same thing?
It was the exact same situation.
Robert Whitaker was fighting
for the interim,
or he had the interim title.
He was going to fight,
I forget who it was.
It was either,
And then he got injured.
They didn't strip him right.
Why they strip Antonio.
Do you feel like it's punishment for him
getting injured a week out?
Like they're pissed and like fuck it
stripped them?
Yeah.
I don't know.
But uh,
that's,
you can't do that so.
Right.
I mean he got heat.
Did Tony wanted to fight more than
anybody?
We've got to buy what you do.
Like if he happens four weeks ago and
it's an injury and training and he tears
it from the bone,
is that they just rescheduled the fight,
right?
Yeah.
And it's still for the interim title.
Why is it like a week out the interim is
canceled?
Maybe it's because they have to make a
big fight with Max Holloway versus could
be before the world.
They have like that cost that cost Tony
a lot of money because he has the
interim belt.
He,
he was,
this was going to be by far is the
biggest pay day ever for him.
I mean,
he was making some good money.
Right?
It's because of the belt.
Because if you strip him his next fight,
he doesn't have that belt anymore to,
to,
to get money,
you know?
And so he'll get significantly less
money.
Say what if you don't have a belt?
Hell yeah.
Let if what if Max or could be wins,
right?
One of them I assume is going to win
whoever wanted is,
and then Tony gets healthy and then
they're going to have tony fight one of
those guys for the title.
Like he would get less than he would
have for this fight if he doesn't have
the belt.
Really?
So that's part of the contract.
If you have a bet with you are going to
negotiate for a fight and you have a
belt,
you have way more power than if you
don't have a belt.
Right.
So by stripping them of the belt,
his next fight,
when he heals up and comes back,
he's going to,
it's going to cost them.
And it's not fair because again,
Robert Winokur didn't get stripped of
his interim belt.
They should Max Holloway and Khabib,
she'd just fight.
Just,
you know,
a main event fight.
It doesn't have to be for a belt because
that's gonna Fuck Tony.
Well,
why would it fuck Tony if he still gets
the interim title?
If he kept the interim title,
then it wouldn't fuck exactly for his
next fight when he negotiates for his
next fight hung and he would be interim
title holder versus world title holder.
Why does Max Maxon and could be and have
to fight for a bell?
It doesn't have to be for a belt.
The UFC holds all the cards.
They can make up the rules,
they can do whatever they want when it
comes to the rankings and stuff.
Right.
They can't do it or whatever they want
when it comes to rules.
So with their,
their position,
they're like,
look,
this is going to cost us shitload of
money.
How do we recover?
Recoup that money?
You know,
how do we a,
okay,
we get Holloway to fight.
Oh,
that's almost as big.
That's a giant fight to,
okay,
now we're back.
Now we're back in business and the
stripping him thing,
I don't know what the policy is on that.
I don't know if there's a public policy
or if it's just,
they just make the call.
I think they could do whatever they want
to do.
Hmm.
I don't,
I don't think they would never give up
that power if they did have it,
like to some organizing body.
Like why would they write cause
organizing bodies could even get
corrupted.
But I think you have to be very careful
when you make like interim titles that
you don't make too many of them and you
don't have them around too often.
You know,
you're like,
once you have them,
you've got to get them resolved pretty
quick.
Like they're,
they,
they're a way to build up excitement
about the fight.
But yeah,
I mean I don't think they would have
stripped him if you got injured four
weeks ago.
But who knows?
I might be wrong.
They might just be,
maybe they have a new policy.
Maybe they just stripping people,
but then conner hasn't fought in 500
days.
It's not stripped.
Yes,
exactly.
Not stripped yet.
Hasn't fought more than 500 days.
MMA.
Last time he fought it was Eddie Alvarez
does his last time in May fight.
That was a long time ago,
man,
as a long time ago.
And then,
uh,
he hasn't been stripped.
So imagine being a lightweight,
just sitting around waiting.
Well,
he's on boxing TV,
having a boxing match and floyd
mayweather,
he doesn't,
if he gets stripped of his title,
it doesn't defend,
it makes 100 million bucks.
They're like,
when you fight fighting again,
and I was like,
who fucking knows?
It would be say shit.
It'd be a lot clear as what to do in
this situation.
If connor would have just fought like a
regular lightweight champion,
there wouldn't be this,
this interim,
uh,
confusion.
It's so good for conor though.
All of it just makes it bigger and
bigger.
It's like Dave,
Dave and changed the rules for him.
You know?
I mean like,
think about that for him.
Like it just makes him bigger.
He hasn't fun 500 days.
Who fucking cares?
He's just rolling around a bathtub full
of hundred dollar bills every day.
Just dive in there and swimming.
He can do whatever the fuck he wants to
see that documentary on Netflix.
No,
I didn't.
It's really good.
Good.
Yeah,
he knew he was going to be a champion
back in the day.
It starts when he,
he has just one tattoo,
the one down,
one down his back.
That's it.
None of the neck tattoos or anything and
he already knew.
He knew he just had dynamite in his
hands,
you know,
crushing people on the local local
scene,
crushing them.
You know one shots,
boom.
Yeah.
I saw him fight in 2013 I think
somewhere around there and his first
chance at DFC,
I wouldn't have known if I didn't see
this documentary.
It's hard to keep track of everything
but wasn't Sweden.
It was a Swedish show.
It was like last minute replacement.
They brought him in and he fought.
What was his name?
Black Guy.
Shit,
I forget his name.
Good guy.
Real good guy.
And he lit him up and that was like damn
after that one fight,
like there's,
there's footage of of him and Dana and
like Dana was already,
he already knew it.
He goes,
man,
I guess the hype was real.
Jesus.
My favorite fights with him or the two
fights with Nate Diaz though.
You know why?
Because those are the fights where he
couldn't put someone away,
just crack them and put them away.
So had to see him fight.
He had a fight and it's a totally
different game.
Like if you see what he did to Eddie
Alvarez,
that was a totally different kind of
fight because he's stung.
Eddie early had him hurt and he was his,
he owned them and then he fucked him up
and stopped him.
That was a beating.
What round was that?
I think it was a second single was a
second and he barely made it out of the
first,
right.
Yeah,
barely made it.
I mean he got fucked up from the get go.
Connor just had us number is way faster
weight quicker and like covering
distance,
just just like laser beams at night.
And I don't think Eddie fought right.
I think Eddie was a little bit too
caught up in the moment is the big hype
of the fight getting to fight conor
mcgregor and he just got fucked up,
kind of had his hands behind his back
and standing right in front of him.
Chicken neck and I'm,
and then pop them in the face like that
was ugly so that you know,
like what year was that?
That was 500 of those 500 days ago.
Like that's the kind of fight is a great
fight for conor,
but that's all hammer.
When he fought nate,
he had to be the nail through a lot of
that.
Yep.
The whole fucking second round of the
first fight.
When nate got them down,
it was the second round submission,
right,
wasn't it?
I Dunno when he submitted him,
but nate's submit them in the second
round.
What are you looking at?
Me Funny when you've got something these
full pull up more than I do with my
Dick.
That's what connor said.
These pull out more than I do with my
deck and like how we got to specify with
his dead.
He must have the only pulled out four
times Max.
That's not that great.
The fights with nate were fights,
you know,
he had to dig deep and he lost the first
one.
He got beat up and got taken down.
He got his back taken.
He got choked.
He tapped.
I mean he fucking lost that fight.
And then the second fight he drops nate.
But he can't put nate away.
Nate gets back up,
they're going after it.
There's fucking times where he's got to
stand and walk away.
He's got walkway cause he's too tired.
He can't engage right now.
Please.
So you've walked away a couple of times
in those exchanges.
Those were dig,
dig fights.
What's this buddy?
Round two.
Yeah.
Okay.
We're submission real Nigga choke four
minutes and 12 seconds it around too.
Yeah.
He beat him down,
warm down and then stopped him.
That's and the fight that conard one.
Could that have gone either?
Yes.
It was arguments that's very close fight
and a really close fight.
I think under the new rules connor
probably would have won because um,
I think,
look,
I think even just one knocked down,
it's not good enough for a 10,
eight round.
It's just not,
you know,
in a,
in a five minute round,
like one knocked down,
it's,
it depends on how the other exchanges
were going.
These changes were all the same and then
you cracked him once.
He definitely won.
But did you win ten eight ten eight is a
beat down I think,
you know,
but even I think that should be wrong.
I don't think it should be that.
I think she'd be like a hundred points
and I think they should have like scores
for like one through 10 in striking,
one through 10 in wrestling,
one through 10 or nonapplicable.
If there's no wrestling at all,
you just attend.
But you got to look at it this way
though.
If,
um,
if you could have a fight and in one
round it's super close and really
nothing happened and just super close
and no one really connected anything.
And that happens all the time.
That's a ten nine round.
Right,
right.
Should,
uh,
and then you compare that to another
round where a guy got dropped but it was
kind of a flash knockdown.
He pops back up and then they,
then it's kind of,
even for the rest of the round,
that can't be a ten nine too.
Right?
So either you got to make more,
10 10 rounds or nine nine rounds,
and then you could say,
okay,
knock down doesn't necessarily mean ten
eight cause then at ten nine is going to
mean one dude.
Clearly one any lamb and some good
shots.
That's a ten nine it's all how you lay
it down.
So if you're going to give,
you know dude who where the round could
have gone either way and you're going to
get someone at ten nine and it looks
just like a dude getting knocked down.
It should,
that should be different.
So it all depends how add more draws or
make it so that if you knock a dude
down,
that's an automatic ten eight round,
you're not going to Dennis ten eight you
knocked him down.
[inaudible] your ass.
What if he's beating your ass all over
the place and then you catch them with
like five seconds to go drop him and he
gets right back up and he cracks you
with a jab.
Do you still get a tenant because you
dropped him?
I think that's a,
I think I would say that's a nine.
Nine.
Yeah,
it's a nine,
nine maybe.
Right?
Cause it depends on how much she's
beating your ass before the guys beating
your ass down the whole round.
And then you clip him once and he drops.
Maybe you weren't really beating him
down that hard.
Maybe it just look like it cause he's
still cracked.
He,
if you were really beating him down,
how was he able to to knock you down?
It happens all the time.
Guys still have power.
Especially if you're running into
something that's a hard one.
That's a hard one to school and knocked
down than a beat down.
You get out class,
the whole match or the whole round and
then you get knocked down once.
Do you remember when the draw Drago Pete
cell fought?
Uh,
Scott Smith.
Scott Smith from rocky four.
No,
I'm kidding.
That's not that.
That's your center.
Do you remember who drago in the second
round against rocky.
We met him.
Remember I talked to Matt Serra's?
I remember Pete Sell Pizza.
Yes.
I know exactly what you're,
Pete dropped,
uh,
hurt.
Um,
Scott Smith real bad with a left hook to
the body.
Like Scott doubled over and winced and
pete moved in for the kill and Scott
just landed the perfect picture point.
But he,
but he was at like,
wasn't,
was hurricane it faking it?
No,
he dropped an agony after he knocked him
out.
Yeah.
Pete Hook to hook them to the body hurt
him real bad.
And when Pete moved in for the kill,
Scott Smith hit him with a per picture.
Perfect.
But I do remember,
I remember that just knocked him out.
He falls back and then Scott Smith's
drops to the ground.
If they stopped the fight and he's in
agony holding onto his side.
It was crazy.
So that can't happen.
Like even if you're beating a guy down
there is still moving if they still just
plant and just uncork one Pat Barry
Check Congo.
Remember that shit?
Pat Barry had check Congo on co we're
street,
he was wobbling all over the place.
It looked like the fight was over and
pat moves in for the kill and boom,
check Congo hits him with the hay maker
as he's running in flatlines Pat Barry
for the first time in his career,
chicken happen.
If you're not knocked out,
you're still moving.
You still could knock someone out.
It can happen,
especially if they get careless.
There it is.
He hits him with the left lead,
this boom.
I mean as a picture perfect left hook to
the body,
but watch this.
He's in agony.
If Pete moves in back home,
I mean that is a crazy right hand.
That's like round nine of a lange versus
Balboa.
I looked at him on the ground and agony
afterwards.
Pizza couldn't even believe it happened.
Yeah,
you should always faint before you move
in.
Always.
Even if you think you got a guy hurt
checks.
Yes.
Fees like this.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
Give me something.
Show me what you got going on.
I mean the best guys,
they never just charged like Max
Holloway.
We fished off.
Aldo is.
It's constant pressure,
constant pressure,
but when he feels Aldo firing bags,
I'll step back for a second.
Right back on your baby.
The best painter,
that's always pretty good.
Damn good at it.
It seems like I just saw someone fight
in the UFC or maybe Bella tour.
That was always just fainting.
Just one boy.
Wonderboy might get my,
my vote
for the best fainter because wonderboy
also has like,
it's like what?
What style?
Faintings most effective wonderboy has
an extra advantage of having that right
leg forward or left leg forward,
whichever he chooses.
Sideway stance with that long body of
his,
that's a weird thing I've dealt with
that man and the old martial arts days
and taekwondo days.
It's the hardest thing to deal with
those long guys that can have a,
that have a powerful front leg.
He just keeps you away.
You don't know what the fuck he's doing,
so he faints and then Bam,
he comes in with a left hand or he
faints and boom is a roundhouse kick in
your face.
I think he's the most,
cause he doesn't also,
it doesn't move like everybody else.
Everybody else has like sort of a
modified taekwondo style or a Moy Thai
style rather,
except for the taekwondo guys.
There's a few guys,
like even connor connor has more of a
karate style.
A lot of the times he'll stand like
total.
Like when you see him fight Aldo,
he stood totally sideways.
I mean he was,
he was bouncing back and forth,
back and forth like a karate fighter.
Remember how Don the Dragon Wilson is
to,
is to just get up on one leg and just
keep his left leg kind of flip it.
Oh,
it just be on one leg and just keep the
left leg all the way up.
Dude.
I sparred with that guy once.
He's annoying.
Right?
Uh,
he's very good at that.
He's very good at that.
He was real nice to try to earn too much
energy.
Well,
he was just not good high kick him.
You could tie kick him dude.
He's good at that too.
If you watch don Wilson's fight with
Dennis Lexio,
Don Wilson fucked Dennis Alexio up back
when?
Dennis Lexia,
I didn't know about leg kicks.
Dennis Alexia want wound up becoming one
of the very best guys that leg kicks.
He was also one of the first guys I ever
saw get his leg broken in a fight.
He fought stan the man longe Anitas and
he had to a grass skirt Australia
and Stan Lodge Nitas he used to work
with my friend Shuki remember Shuki the,
the,
the uh,
the Israeli guy who was teaching me
kickboxing back in your day,
his leg was all fucked up because he
would hold pads for Stan longe Anitas he
had that big old type leg pad at home.
Like if you think some people,
like if you see a guy who kicks real
hard,
right?
The heavyweight world champion Moitai
guys or Thai boxer,
a kickboxer guys like a standalone.
Janine is the power they have in their
Kik is unfathomable.
I remember I brought this up with you,
but you say it wasn't you.
I was at Beverly Hills Jujitsu once and
we were watching Pedro his,
oh,
kick the bag.
And I was like,
what?
Like you just think of one of those
slamming into your thigh and you're
like,
there's no way.
There's no way.
He shook,
his whole leg was fucked up and holding
the pat on one side.
He was gonna need a hip replacement.
Damn Dude.
Magic.
I kicked your leg while you're holding
pads for him so hard.
You need a hip replacement.
What was not worth it on the Dragon?
Wilson beat the beat.
Um,
Dennis Alexia with leg kicks with my
point.
But Don had that weird style.
Like he would stand totally sideways and
he didn't take any chances.
He fought superintelligent.
He fought deep into his forties to man.
He's an Oj.
Yeah.
Commentary with him.
He was my partner in King of the cage
for maybe five or six shows.
Man.
Talk about the worst co commentary ever.
Me and Donna driving was really bad.
Oh yeah.
Can you imagine a na commentary is?
It's not,
that's not my Gig,
man.
I could do color,
but being the play by play guy,
that's just a whole,
that's a whole different animal with,
with Phil Baroni.
Ronnie was fucking hilarious.
It was the Miami show.
Yup.
We got to get tiny UFC in Miami.
I think that was the only one ever.
Right.
Um,
I don't know about that.
This is gone.
The Dragon.
Don Wilson.
Who was he fighting here?
There he is.
Look at him in these red pants.
Oh,
it's him fighting Dennis Lexio.
Yeah.
See how he would just flip that thing
out?
Everything was like light and flippy and
they just,
they couldn't,
he didn't know what to do with it.
They couldn't kick to the legs,
right?
Oh,
they could.
Or they could wait.
Oh,
look at that site.
You know,
they could see you just kicked him in
the leg right there.
Don Wilson fucked him up with low kicks
in this fight.
See?
Desolo Alexia was trying to kick them in
the legs.
This is after what had happened was a
lot of these guys like Don Wilson that
had a traditional karate background,
learn how to kickbox.
They realized how potent leg kicks were.
A big factor was rick the Jet Rufus Du
group as his brother,
who was one of the all time best pka
style above the waist.
Kickboxers Rick Rufus.
When I was a kid,
man,
I want it to be like Rick Rufus.
He would fight dude sideways stance and
just fucked him up,
fucked him up with a hook kicks and
roundhouse kicks and dive in with
punches like blitz karate style punches.
I mean Rick Rufus was doing shit that
nobody was doing and he fought his tie.
Dude,
I do not remember the gentleman's name,
but Duke roufus brought it up.
I'll podcast is being like a big
transformation in his life cause that
top side you fight is just chopped.
Rick down.
Just chose those legs like a mix rules,
a little bit of Muay Thai,
a little bit of American kickbox and
they allowed the leg kicks but they
didn't allow elbows or something like
that exact set up and and a k one.
Yes.
Here it is.
What does it the guy's name?
Yeah,
the fight that hug out was pause that
real quick.
Chang's Plec Keyapp Song Grit Kyat some
[inaudible] Chang quick Chinese quick
Yuck Song Grit.
Which okay.
Record.
Oh well yeah,
he had like more than a hundred
professional fights.
I mean he was a world champion.
He wasn't an okay guy.
Yeah,
he was really good.
Okay.
I thought he was a beast.
He,
okay.
Let's see what his,
what he was fucking him up with his
hands though.
Rick roof was fucking him up with his
hands.
Had Him hurt,
had him almost knocked out a couple of
times,
but he kept landing those leg kicks and
the leg kicks back.
Had to be carried off in a stretcher.
He couldn't fight because he couldn't
walk down his legs gave out,
gone.
Well,
he didn't know what it was there.
So I mean it'd be,
this is like a long time ago.
He didn't understand,
but he tagged with some punches,
man.
He could hurt.
He could hang with his hands.
No,
we'll get that spinning back fist and
the punch behind it,
he was fucking him up.
He really was fumbling by little,
he was landing them like his little Thai
guy is though to take those shots.
One of the greatest back fights ever.
And kickboxing history.
Just,
just the fact that this is how Rick
Rufus learned the power of who that
fucking go back there real quick.
Go back there guys.
Almost go back.
Watch this.
Look at this move that he does.
He does that.
A touch jumping side posts,
spinning wheel kick hit him in the head.
Dudes out on his feet at the end of the
bell,
they sit them down in the corner,
out on his feet.
Just keep playing.
This one of the greatest matches that's
of all time.
So historically significant in martial
arts.
This is why this is where they learned.
Yes.
This is one of those American
kickboxers.
This is,
this is was an eye opener.
This is like UFC one for kickboxing.
Dude.
I remember the first,
the first time someone ever kicked me in
the leg and they didn't even do it hard.
They did it to show me like how hard it
is when you get kicked in the leg.
It was like a light bulb went off.
Oh No.
The first time I've ever heard of a leg
kick.
I was,
uh,
working at the Strip club as a DJ and
one of the managers was all into karate.
He turned them into,
you always had done tournament karate
for 12.
Oh Shit.
Look at this dude.
He's lightened him up with his leg
kicks.
And then,
uh,
he took me in the back one day and he
goes,
dude,
stand there.
Let me kick you.
And he kicked me with his shin.
He goes,
people are doing this now.
How does that feel?
Does he wasn't,
she was experimenting on mine legs.
Does this hurt their lending with their
shin?
And I'm like,
damn it.
Fuck that a lot.
Their Shins.
That's weird.
Well,
the crazy thing is when you feel it for
like from someone who's just like
tapping your leg,
how much it hurts.
Now think of this dude whose name I
can't pronounce again.
Oh look.
So rick would try to throw his own kick,
but his low kicks were like foot kicks.
The,
I mean,
he was a foot kicker.
He wasn't like a Shin Kicker back then.
Like most karate guys,
we're in step kickers.
You would hit a guy with a roundhouse
kick,
but you had hit him in the body with
your instep.
You hit him in the head with your
instep.
Almost everything I ever did up until I
started doing Moitai was with my insteps
or the heel like heel kicks.
We'll kicks.
Stuff like that was incredible that
Americans didn't figure that out.
You know?
Isn't that killed him in the leg yet?
I mean this is crazy shit.
Did he hit him with a punch on the way
down?
Back that up again real quick.
Just out.
Just a hair.
Look at this.
He goes down.
Yeah.
He elbowed him in the back of the head.
Holy Shit Dude.
Show that again.
Watch this again.
Watch what happens.
He goes down and on the way down,
watch this.
Boom.
See that elbow,
Yo dude,
no doubt.
Dirty elbow to the back of the dome.
One more time please.
One more time.
Please.
Look at this down on its way down.
Watch his left.
Boom.
He fucking cracked the back of his head
with the help of referee.
Didn't even know what an elbow was.
That's an invalid technique.
You're tenured,
you miss a punch.
Landed
with his elbow,
tried and land a punch.
Buddy.
Dot.
Going to take any points away because
you didn't land,
Dude.
He's fucking that right leg up south
potter southpaw.
Oh,
look at that and made him switch.
Dance is,
look at that.
He's chopping them down.
Dude.
You can't even imagine how bad this must
hurt for Rick Rufus and the middle of
this fight.
He doesn't know how to block these
things.
He's taken one on the front leg,
one on the back leg.
He's just getting crushed.
I mean,
this is crazy.
You want to cross the front with a Dick?
Is duties flatfooted now he can't to
bullying.
Can't spin.
He can't spend.
Look at this.
Accompanied by a stomp.
He stopped him.
Oh,
that's top to the body was legit.
Oh my God.
Damn.
They need to make a movie out of this.
This is crazy.
They should make a move.
They should make a documentary from the
boy.
A pour a tie fighter.
Right,
and rufus like make rick roof is the
evil white guy.
He can't.
He wants to blow up the world.
He can't even move.
This is like,
these guys are so important.
It's so important to our understanding
because Rick Rufus was so good.
He was so good and he was doing movies,
shit on people.
Those jump,
roundhouse kick,
Spinning Hook kicks.
Look at this round too.
I mean he was doing some really wild
shit and even landing it on this guy
like he was fucking good.
He was a legit champion,
no doubt about it,
but he just did not understand the low
kick game yet and this was,
it was so important for a guy.
Look at that.
He lands that high kick.
It's,
it was so important that a guy,
as good as him fought this guy so we
know for sure it wasn't just that,
you know the ric rufus wasn't any good.
No rich rufus was fogging or real good.
Real good.
Then too.
He's getting crushed with those
and this tie guys look at as open hands
to look how he's moving forward.
Just open hands.
He's all about protecting himself,
pushing off and low kicking.
Look at his hands.
See His hand placement.
I mean,
that's crazy shit.
Look at that.
Boom,
pushing off.
He's barely even tried to punch with
them.
He's basically just using his hands to
create space and distance and give Rick
Rick roof is something to think about
and to block the punches in the kick
that rufus throws and then boom leg
kicks.
He just leg kicks him to death.
Look at that.
He's not punching.
He's just leg kick.
Leg kick.
Hands up,
hands up like that is crazy.
As soon as he stopped exchanging
punches,
he just started dominating the space and
then slamming those leg kicks in.
Look at that.
Boom.
Fakes with the hand and across both
thighs.
That's one of the most painful ones,
man.
The ones across both thighs.
Ah,
ah.
Rob came in back when I was getting
coaching from him.
He tapped me across the front of my
thoughts with his shin.
Just dunk.
Just tapped me.
My legs hurt all day.
This guy.
Wow.
Really that throw holy Shit.
Those ties.
Can Chuck each other around.
Two man
round posted a little clip.
Oh Shit.
Look at that.
Of a fight where they had,
didn't they just wrapped up their hands?
They didn't have gloves and the head
butts were legal.
It was kickboxing or you could throw
pieces and you could have,
but did you see that clip?
No Dude,
it's evil guy headbutts his opponent
standing up.
He just,
just spears his head right into a knocks
the guy down just from a headbutt and
rufus.
Like he only stands that one way most of
the time too.
So that that front right leg is so
vulnerable to that left outside kick
cause they're both southpaw.
If rucc rick see now he's trying to
switch up and he's putting his left leg
forward cause he's in so much pain.
Like look,
when he walks back to his corner do he
could barely walk at the end of the
third round.
Barely.
Was this in Thailand or was in the
states?
I don't know where it was.
It looks,
it says cores,
beer on the canvas.
I want to think it's in America and plus
the way they're making them where he's
wearing those pants.
I got to think it's America.
Those pants look so stupid in
comparison.
And also Rick Rufus was also wearing
pads on his feet.
Oh Shit.
How did he go down their leg?
Kick another leg.
Can you rewind that Jamie?
Look at the pads.
Look at the pads on his feet.
Okay,
here,
look at this.
How does he go down?
Oh that was just the leg kick.
Yeah,
just low kick caught him in the spin and
just totally took his leg out and he's
wearing those,
those booties on the tops of his feet to
like to protect the bones of his feet
cause he's a foot kicker.
See what I'm saying?
Like that's extra weight.
You were an extra four ounces or
whatever the fuck it is on your feet.
It slows your kicks down and the Thai
guy just says taped up ankles and shorts
on.
It's really interesting because it's
really is like kickboxing versus Moitai
pool and we chopped the leg gambling,
we chops late.
Again,
look at this work roof is in so much
danger here.
I mean he's basically just totally
helpless.
And this tie guys going across the
shins.
He's going across the,
if he's blocking with his knee,
he doesn't give a fuck.
He's just kicking through him
everything.
Boom.
Look at that.
Boom,
look at that.
He's just walking him down.
Boom.
And then another one,
no terrifying.
That must be to have that guy walk you
down like that.
Hands out like that.
They call the fight,
I think is that jt will the referee is a
famous referee who got it was will and
like all those karate.
That's Dick Dude.
That's Duke right there.
Now that's not jql.
That's a duke right there.
Uh,
telling everybody that he didn't think
that it took a lot of skill to kick
someone's legs.
I think
rick should've won the fight.
He had the guy,
big historical stuff.
The way the cookie crumbles tonight.
Let's take a look at the monitor down
here,
Jeff,
and
became like the man,
look at this.
Bam there,
you know,
he says buck on his knees to do the same
type of injury that Angela football
player's career.
You know,
I don't think it takes much town to kick
somebody in the legs as you thought.
Those jumping,
what's crazy now eric?
We're throwing in all deep and real
town.
Well,
it was crazy.
I mean,
Duke I think was only 19 at the time.
You know,
he's changed.
He's,
he's learned.
And one of the reasons why he's so good
is because he's open minded,
but he became a world champion,
more Thai fighter himself,
which is crazy.
It's just like Jujitsu and leg locks.
I know what I mean.
It's just like that,
that doesn't take any town.
You're just jumping on a guy's lag,
dude.
All,
all martial arts techniques that are
effective,
there's still people that don't believe
in certain techniques.
And the big,
uh,
another big moment for Maury tie in the
history of that martial art was,
uh,
Paul Varland versus Marco.
Who else?
That's when we saw was UFC seven.
That's when we saw the damn cause before
UFC seven,
everybody was thinking,
okay,
you can't really do any kind of striking
you.
You,
you have to learn Jujitsu or you will
lose.
It's going to be,
people were just losing faith in
striking all together,
like just work on,
um,
uh,
it,
it was almost like jabs didn't even work
back then.
Like who throws a jab in mma?
You're going to get taken down and get
choked out.
And UFC seven,
that's when we learned,
okay,
leg leg kicks work.
You got to 300 pounds.
Yeah.
That changed everything.
Portland's violence was huge.
The polar bear there.
Call them tech.
I was gigantic.
And Marco who washes took his legs
and then marco,
who was,
he also beat revco par do that judo
champion.
You remember he mounted them and then
tap.
He goes,
it's over.
Once you get them out.
That's what he thought.
That's it.
That is what he thought.
Isn't that crazy?
Look at this marco.
Who else would get heel hooks on people
and shit?
Who's he fighting?
Says,
yeah,
I get some in the heel hook right here
for this.
I think this is the first he'll hook in.
The UFC.
Might've been if it wasn't him,
it was,
um,
oh,
that's amazing.
Oh,
wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Maybe he Ken Shamrock against Patrick
Smith.
Yes.
I don't know if that was a heel and
ankle walk.
[inaudible]
I dunno.
A heel hook.
Yeah.
Ken probably had the first ever leg lock
and then I was going to say,
oh look,
tech tar off didn't all that gets him
heal hooks.
He got a knee bar and a straight ankle
lock I think.
Oh old school son.
Old Kinda mma show revealing old fights.
Man King in the streets,
baby.
Give me five Paul Paul Varland.
It's v a are viral and you were talking
to Eric Apple about his old days
sparring with Marco.
They would spar Brazilian style,
get ready for concussions.
It's just,
yeah,
it didn't matter if you get your nose
broken,
get back in there like everybody was
just going to war.
That's what dad,
everyone was scared to death of back in
the early days and I was a white belt
ever.
You hear about health gracie school up
in it's Paul violence versus that Marco,
who was versus that's Paul violence
fighting.
It looks like in a pre UFC fight or
maybe after his UFC career.
He was,
he was a master of was it trapped?
Fighting?
I Dunno.
I think it was trapped and that you're
really,
there it is right there at the top.
It's the UFC.
UFC.
He wore a singlet.
Remember he wore a wrestling singlet?
Yeah.
Like look,
he's six.
Seven.
Can you get this big fella?
Can you wear those singlets anymore?
You can't write.
No.
Why not?
Uh,
it's a good question.
Girls can,
well actually it looks like he's got
different colored shorts on or is that
the Monitor?
So he's a tank top.
Is a tank top on?
He's fighting with a tank top on.
It's not even a single it right.
It looks like a singlet.
It a little bit,
but doesn't look like different colors.
Well,
maybe you're right.
Maybe it's just we're seeing his legs
and yeah,
it probably is going to the last minute.
It has a phone.
The last minute of the fight,
that's where he chops him down.
He just chopped him down there with the
first one.
Boom.
He's so much smaller than I look how
small Marco is in comparison to Marco's
a bit guy.
Boom.
See Paul violence doesn't have any idea
what to do here.
So he,
he just keeps kicking back.
Oh,
he just touched his leg.
He did.
Oh boom.
Oh,
chop them down.
Your fucks now.
So,
and Marco just got on top of him a trop
to hammers on them.
Boom.
No gloves.
Yeah.
Old School.
After that,
everyone started throwing a leg kicks
firmly believe we need to go back to no
gloves.
Firmly believe.
I can't emphasize it enough.
I think people would get less hurt.
I think you'd,
it'd be a more realistic,
you got to have Rogan fighting
championships on an Indian reservation.
I don't think it makes that.
I mean,
I'm beating a dead horse.
I know I'm a broken record.
I just don't think it makes sense to
tape your wrists up.
Your wrists are very vulnerable.
You shouldn't be able to just make a
cast out of them and slam him into
things.
I feel the same way about your ankles.
Like,
imagine if you could tape your wrist up
to the point where nobody or your ankle
up to a point where nobody could ever
get you in a foot lock cause your ankle
was protected.
That'd be ridiculous,
right?
We'll essentially,
when you get someone in a wrist lock,
what are you doing?
You're pulling against the wrist.
Well,
is that a valid technique?
Okay.
A valid technique like a wrist lock like
this,
very hard to do when someone's risks is
taped the fuck up.
When your wrist is really Rocco right
across here,
it goes all over your knuckles.
It goes all around new arrest.
He goes all around your wrist and makes
it much more stable.
You can really dig into things.
It feels way better.
It feels way better to hit things
because when you don't,
especially like my hand is bigger than
my wrist,
so if I hit things on either side,
it'll be like more wobbly.
You want it that you want that bitch
taped up,
you know?
Yeah.
And even if your hand is the exact same
size as your wrist man,
it's just,
this is a joint that is a super
articulating look at this wrist and he
looked at all the stuff your risk does.
Your wrist is crazy.
It really think about joints is the only
joint like it.
Your knees don't do that shit.
I guess your shoulders are kind of
crazy,
but your wrists,
when you're punching,
you would have to develop some serious,
strengthen your forearms to be able to
be a really effective bare knuckle
fight.
I mean truly bare knuckle,
no wraps in your hands.
No nothing.
Just truly knuckle you had.
You had also learned that you must punch
things with the top knuckles.
You have to,
and even then you could break them.
But if you start hitting,
people in the jaw are great there with
this crack,
this fucking thing is just going to
break.
Hit somebody in the forehead right here,
crack.
It's going to break.
You're going to break them.
You get elbows,
break them for sure you're gonna break
up.
But with those gloves on,
you get away with that shit.
You can get away with that shit and you
could,
you could pitty pat guys,
you could do that more and just not even
like tried to find like specific spots.
Just start hitting them.
You can't do that.
You have to make sure you're getting the
soft tissue.
You've got to target soft tissue.
You've got to look for the job.
Bang.
Body appears to the public to be more
brutal.
Right?
If you don't,
right.
Listen man,
all you need to do is watch anybody
kicked somebody.
Just think the fact that we let someone
slammed their fucking Shin into some
dude's face.
That is watch Jeremy Stevens when Jeremy
Stevens fought Honney j uh,
what's his name?
Honey.
Jason,
remember honey?
Jason.
Jeremy Stevens.
Hi Jason.
It is like the head kick to end all head
kicks.
I don't remember.
Oh shut up.
You guys aren't allowed to pull up like
a,
you'll see footage.
I wish we could we switch to have a
special exemption from the past.
Like maybe like promote bypass every
time you use it.
That would be good.
Great way to promote it.
Right?
They would let us thing one time,
like they reached out and said like
here's an account,
but then they never responded.
I was like,
okay,
let and then,
but that'd be a great way to promote it.
But yeah,
I'll talk to the UFC.
I'll try to see what we can get done on
your show.
You could talk about fights and and have
no issues with pulling up the awesome.
That would be huge for them.
That would,
it's free.
They don't pay me for this and that's,
that's how people would do it at home.
Maybe hanging out with their friends
going,
fuck,
remember that one fight.
Put It on fine.
You coming in New York this weekend
anyway?
No.
Come to New York.
No,
no.
Cause I gotta be there the next week.
Anyways,
I got to go to Brooklyn again the
following weekend.
Geo is fighting Gordon Ryan's brother.
Oh Shit.
That's been,
that's going to be amazing.
It's going to be awesome,
man.
Those guys are awesome.
I love the level of Jujitsu that's
available right now.
It's way better than ever.
I mean,
the level of just the purple belts these
days would destroy purple belts of like
eight years ago.
Amazing.
It's crazy.
And it keeps going up and up to,
I was watching some videos today online.
Instagram's huge.
The loop when you watch a technique and
you can just watch it over and over
again.
Exactly.
Yeah.
That makes,
that accelerates the learning process so
much.
I was watching a clip today.
I washed it like 15 times in a row.
It was,
I'm a Cyborg during that Tornado guard
pass,
uh,
on some big giant Dude Cyborg Bjj I
think is this thing.
He hit this giant dude with that tornado
sweep,
you know,
he does that.
He gets under you and spins and rolls
over.
Very,
very interesting to watch be people can
do that.
That's so strong.
But that's what his post was about.
His posters about technique.
And is that like your technique is like
the steering wheel,
but your strength is the engine?
Yes.
I believe that.
I believe that too.
I mean every top pro athlete has a
serious strength and conditioning
program.
You look at Gordon Ryan's body.
Yeah.
Well that kid's body,
that kids our goal.
Rilla you know it's not,
it's not a coincidence that he's jacked
as fuck and has awesome technique and
taps.
Cyborg.
You think about how good Cyborg as then
think about him tap and Cyborg and tap
them pretty handedly.
That sweet man,
boom,
that was Orlando Sanchez is 300 pounds.
Exactly.
That's why it's crazy.
That's why it's quite quick.
Big that sits there.
Look at this suite.
We get a sweep leg up in the air and a
hand to foot in between the legs and
then he pushes the hip with his hand.
That's one of the greatest sweeps of all
time.
Of all time.
The Shit.
Look,
look at this.
So he gets hunger.
He using his foot as he tucks him under
and pushes him.
I'd like to know what the amazing like
to know where the left hand is left hand
on the hip.
Watch how he rolls when he rolls him.
Watched his left hand,
his right hand on top of the left hand
seat on the hip.
See it pushing where?
Hushing hip though.
Like it looks.
It's hard.
It's right here.
You probably just getting anything that
he can.
It's flat.
If you look at the way w w what was he?
The left hand.
His left hamstring has got to be so
strong.
Oh Dude.
He's a gorilla.
Left hamstring.
Insane.
Right?
But he is excellent.
Even just a hamstring cause he looks to
me like his foot sideways and he'd
watching.
He does it again.
Look,
it's foot is sideways like a sidekick.
look at that.
I mean it's like he's going against the
inside of the leg.
This is what's even crazier.
The strain is like the abductor muscles.
He's going like this way.
That's another look at,
look at his left leg blocking dude's
left arm ours,
right?
Like I'm sorry,
the right leg.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
And that guy he just swept is an adcc
gold medalist and 300 pounds and he's a
really good wrestler.
He's a black belt in Jujitsu.
That right then that shit that he should
just leave that on a loop at of school.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Well,
cyborgs of gorilla.
He's got an ma.
Did you see ever see it as strength and
conditioning routines?
I know that motherfucker doesn't play,
dude.
He's a real law.
He's a goal.
All the top guy.
Oh yeah.
I just saw a Andra Galvao doing dead
lifts today.
Yes,
garage.
He,
let me ask you this.
Is it better to just let the deadline,
I was going to ask you that because of
that.
When he dead lifts,
is that best way to do it?
You tell me.
I don't know.
Shit.
I don't know shit either.
I would always think that the negatives
are important.
I mean the negatives for me are very
important.
Like for Chin ups,
I go way slower going down.
It seems like every six months there's a
whole new philosophy on I'm strength I
can.
It's totally the opposite of the last
one.
So crazy.
It's like now the big thing is,
you know with intermittent fasting it's
like,
okay,
there's all these diets and eat this and
gluten that and all that and then now
the new diet is donated for 18 hours and
no,
it's not crazy.
That is crazy,
dude.
That shit works.
You know what's great about that is it
makes you have
a time every day where you can have the
most fabulous meal ever.
Cause when I,
when I eat,
I'm starving and salads taste.
So good luck.
I want a big key.
I of a double salad.
Yeah.
And when you're not,
when you're not that hungry,
it fee it now.
Now I feel like if I'm not that hungry,
I don't want to waste a meal because
it's so much better when you're starving
and you're out of control.
Yeah.
I eat that way most of the time,
except on days when I know I have a
really brutal workout in the morning,
like a weight lift and work.
I'll run fasted,
I'll do yoga fasted.
But if I'm going to lift,
I want to have something I need.
I need some fruit or some,
it's almost three right now.
I haven't eaten at all and I'm fine.
I'm fine.
You know,
it's a,
it's um,
interesting diet.
I hope it isn't bullshit.
No,
it's definitely not bullshit.
I was never a morning person either.
Like I never did.
I never really looked forward to
breakfast was always add and have I got
protein bar or something just cause I
had to,
did you ever listen to my podcast?
I did with Dom D'agostino.
He's a scientist from,
I think he's University of Florida.
Um,
but uh,
a key to genic specialist does a lot of
Quito research and research on fasting
and the benefits of fasting and he goes
into the scientific benefits,
the proven benefits of fasting.
Very,
very interesting stuff.
What did he,
what were,
what were the most I would really want
to direct you to that.
I want to fuck it up,
but it's for a preventative cancer.
Um,
yeah.
Ketone bodies in the blood and crease
cognitive improvements.
I just think we eat too much.
We eat too much meat all the time.
So easy to know.
I like watching TV and snacking,
you know,
watch a little netflix snacks.
We all do.
But if I'm watching Netflix and it's
nine o'clock at night,
I really shouldn't be eating.
Isn't it weird that like popcorn became
the official food watching movies?
Isn't that weird?
I know it's loud chewing shit.
You can't hear dialogue and have no one
likes to say,
dude,
let's go get some popcorn.
No one,
no one ever looks for popcorn and less
they're at the movies.
That's a good point.
What is it only time?
Maybe a Disneyland because it's like,
Yay,
I forgot about popcorn.
Fucking and by that while I'm here too.
Other than that,
like the circus movie,
circus,
popcorn,
circus got peanuts into the mix.
Maybe there's something about the
popcorn that like it's like genetically
modified and it's like it helps with
the,
with the brainwashing just in the palm
court.
Yeah,
probably do up to microwave,
dude.
That's what it is.
They might exact curls and it fucks with
your head Bro.
Basically microwave,
just kill everything.
Right.
When you might go into your food,
you basically just don't have anything.
It's just like,
yeah,
pop,
pop.
I'm not hung.
Survived in a way.
Right.
Isn't it crazy that we haven't really
improved upon micro?
It's like they mastered that shit 40
years ago and it's still the same
goddamn micro.
I know it's really bad for you and
they're going to take out of microwave
popcorn.
When you get popcorn,
there's fats in there that your body
just doesn't know what the fuck to do
with.
That's where those things could sit on a
shelf for so long.
Those little packets,
I think,
what is it?
What is the toxic ingredient in
microwave popcorn that they're
eliminating?
It's hilarious.
They decided,
Oh,
this shit kills you,
but we're going to let you sell it for
two more years.
They didn't just make it illegal.
They made a moratorium.
I think it's trans fats.
I think it just might be a vegetable.
Oil Fats.
There's certain certain trans fats that
are just,
your body's just like,
what in the fuck is this non food?
You're,
you're making me.
Yeah.
We were talking about delicious protein
bars before the show.
That gives you the most unbelievable
farts.
That's how I know I shouldn't be eating,
so if I'm,
if I'm eating something and I'm just
lighten the inside of my car on fire
chemical here it is.
Chemicals used in aligning of
microwaveable popcorn bags including
look per fluoro.
[inaudible]
acid or Pfo are part of a class of
compounds that may be linked to
infertility and humans.
According to a recent study from Ucla
and animal testing,
the chemicals caused liver cancer,
tech,
testicular cancer and pancreatic cancer.
So that's one thing,
but I know that they banned trans fats.
I might have conflated the two stories.
Did that,
cause what is the ban of trans fats is
the one where they're giving them like
all the like hostess cakes,
those bullshit cakes that sit on the
shelf forever.
Ding dongs are my favorite.
Those things,
those,
those pop,
those pie cakes that you get from hosted
to like the lemon filling,
those are just trans fats to the gills.
Twinkie method.
They last 20 years or whatever.
How long do they last?
Twinkie like you and I were laying
around in fucking bored,
smoked a little weed,
watching some TV and up to God.
I'm so hungry.
When he got here,
man cabinet and you had like ring dings,
twinkies and my grab a twinkie.
If I'm starving laying around watching
survival chillin,
I might eat a twinkie.
These are like the worst wedding cake.
It's just,
well,
you know what I had last night at
strawberry shortcake,
US popcorn makers could face long,
expensive road to lose trans fats.
Okay?
This is why I conflated it.
Microwave popcorn makers could face a
long and difficult task.
Ridding their snacks of trans fats,
US Food and Drug Administration proposal
to ban the additive goes into effect.
So you s is banning.
So the u s ban on Trans Fats is what I
uh,
what I got confused with us ban on trans
fats is like a,
they're given these people like two
years.
Isn't it crazy that they're there?
They're going to make it a big deal out
of this.
They're going after the trans fats,
but they don't go after like,
like,
like real shit.
Like alcohol is like killing people all
day every day.
I know,
right?
It's like you,
you say,
why don't you say this is going to kill
you if you keep eating it,
but it's awesome but you're going after
trans fats.
Maybe it's like someone,
someone in the popcorn industry just
pissed off and I illuminati Mammogram,
you know where to go after him.
And this,
is this like a smear campaign?
Trans Fats,
danger?
No,
they're bad for you once they know
they're bad for you.
But what about just take him,
what about the,
that one drug that everyone's getting
addicted to that's legal.
Uh,
adderall.
No,
it's,
it's a Carolyn.
It's morphine.
No,
no,
no.
Very popular.
Very popular prescription.
Oxycontin.
Oxycontin for sure.
Fuck your life up 100% but he have
serious pain.
It also leaves yeates pain.
And the thing is,
can you,
can you just write it for a few and
they're going after trans fats here.
It's crazy.
Let them have their popcorn.
Fuck Aa.
They're going,
they're making like news articles about
it.
[inaudible] after Trans Fat.
What about the 800 kids that go missing
every year?
What about,
why don't you cold weld?
Different people go look for that.
Okay,
that's true.
But these are different people.
These are food scientists.
But I think the point is that this stuff
that there's other ways to make food,
but the thing is,
I don't know what is the benefits of
Trans Fats?
Does it make processing easier?
Like,
why do they use that as opposed to like
other healthy fats?
I don't know why.
It probably has something to do with
shelf life maybe.
Yes,
probably.
That's probably why it fucks you up too.
You got to think about what a
preservative is.
You know,
like someone was explaining,
did you see,
uh,
what's wrong with wheat or what's with
wheat?
Did you see that documentary?
Maybe they were talking about roundup
and glyphosate and they were talking
about roundup,
this stuff that they spray on some
plants that they said,
well don't worry,
this only affects a bacteria.
Yeah,
and so they said that,
well,
this one,
they were creating it and this is one of
the reasons why they allowed it to be
used,
but what they are explaining in this
documentary,
it's just,
I don't know if it's true or not,
but what they were explaining was,
yeah,
you have bacteria in your body dummy.
Like you're taking this stuff into your
body.
They didn't say it that way.
You have bacteria in your body.
You're taking this stuff into your body
that only kills bacteria.
It's going to kill a part of your body.
Like your body is partly bacteria.
In fact,
there's more bacteria cells in your body
than there are human cells.
That's just a fact of being a person.
So this is a crazy thing that they don't
know that and they either know it and
they did it anyway or they didn't know
that in which the case,
what you were saying earlier,
they should have no business telling
people what's the good science and the
bad science if they allow that to go
through it.
Yeah.
That's another example of bad science.
Yeah,
well it's definitely example of maybe
they didn't know when they first came up
with the stuff,
but as technology has advanced,
they haven't eliminated it either way.
Whether they didn't know or they did
know and there was a diabolical plan,
whatever it is,
it's just,
it's that science is bogus.
Yeah,
but should you be allowed like we know
diet cokes,
terrible for you.
Should you be allowed to sell diet coke
if you want,
but just most do most people know how
bad diet coke is for you or Diet Soda?
I should say the most people know.
Most people don't.
They don't know.
Mostly Park.
I'll have a diet every now and again
once a month or so I'll have a diet
coke.
I been pretty good at keeping sodas at
my life now.
We discovered a,
the Pellegrino.
Yeah.
Pellegrinos great.
Yeah,
just water.
I love it.
I used to struggle with being at a
restaurant and you're struggling with,
should I just drink water or can I get a
fucking,
I'm gonna have a coke and then I have to
coax and then I feel guilty all night.
Uh,
that struggle went on my whole life,
dude.
I been drinking way too much.
Water.
Pellegrino,
the Pellegrino that tie that in Perrier,
that,
that satisfies me enough.
ZV is a good one too.
And um,
there's a couple of other like flavored
waters.
They're like more carbonated.
It's carbonated water.
Ah,
the Cla,
the Cla is Pellegrino and carbonated
waters.
Is that bad for you?
Is that gonna is that gonna come out
that we get cancer from that are the
bubbles fucking me up.
They are not good for your teeth.
What do they do?
The bubbles,
just as bad as soda.
Water is.
I mean it's just not good for your,
it's soda isn't Pellegrino has settled
water.
It's the same thing.
And carbonated water is bad for your
teeth and mass amounts.
I mean like one or two,
probably not a bad thing.
So we'll just drink it about once it
gets in your stomach that do the
bubbles,
do the bubbles like fuck you up.
Gas,
Illuminati Bro.
They're all ideas.
Those,
those ideas in those bubbles getting you
to buy into bonds.
Who knows?
Maybe maybe they find out that the
bubble of your guns,
your system do something,
uh,
bad for Ya.
Yeah,
right.
I mean,
I wouldn't be surprised.
I hope not shit out.
It's completely benign because I turned
her,
we've heard about the shit out of it.
I do too.
Here along as it's playing carbonated
water with no added citric acid or
sugar,
the answer is no.
The process of carbonation is simple.
Addition of pasteurized,
pressurized carbon dioxide,
gas into plain water acids,
sugars and salt,
or not being added.
It's the addition of those ingredients
that ups your risk for tooth decay.
So no harm at all.
So it's just carbonated water is just
carbon dioxide gas or maybe that's an
Illuminati.
Dude,
stop freaking me out,
man.
Did you know the funguses fucking like
mushrooms?
They breathe in oxygen and breathe out
carbon dioxide like we do.
Does that make it make it good?
It's like an animal more than it is like
a plant.
They're closer to animals than they are
to plants.
A fungus,
fungus or like an animal.
Almost.
Not really because it doesn't move.
I mean,
but it's closer to the animal wrangler
moves
shit.
Yeah.
Fuck that fungus.
That's the worst man.
That's the worst.
But like mushrooms are there.
There's some sort of other thing.
They're not a plant funguses and a
different kind of thing,
uh,
from another fucking planet,
man.
That's what I think.
You think mushrooms aren't legal right?
They're not.
There's that recreational mushrooms are
the ballot for 2000 coming California.
Any states already legalized my,
but they should.
They should do it the same way they do
what
they're going to eventually do with
Mtma.
Look,
mushrooms are great,
and remember the first time you,
and I remember the first time you and I
did mushrooms,
you were living at your old house.
We were chilling in the backyard,
dude,
and we to do the talking about life
wasn't that much.
It a small dose,
but it was enough to go whoa.
Like it just gave me a better
perspective.
It's just opened up my mind to that.
I was,
I was relying on all the patterns that
had been explained to me about life to
be correct instead of like looking at it
with fresh eyes.
And I felt like at 30 years old,
it was the first time I was able to look
at my,
my life with fresh eyes,
look at life itself and go,
oh,
this is just this weird temporary
experience eating your comedy,
tear your comedy.
Just,
you know,
from,
from the early Joe Rogan,
like your first CD somebody someday I'm
going to be dead.
Right.
I'm going to be dead someday.
From that comedy to the once you started
getting into psychedelics,
big o difference.
Yeah.
It changes who you are cause well,
it also makes you super humble because
even if I don't appear humble,
um,
when you,
when you get hit by that,
that the big dose,
whatever it is,
dmt or whatever you do,
when you get hit by that dose,
you realize you are just a part.
You're not the big thing.
It is a part of something that is
indescribably big.
And the idea that you're important or
that you're the most significant thing
around you,
it's pretty ridiculous.
Like you gotta do your best to keep your
body alive and do your best to do your
part and whatever the fuck you do for a
living,
do your best at that.
But you're just a part of something
that's infinite.
Did your experience with mushrooms and
Dmt,
did that make you think like there's
gotta be a creator to all this?
Not that there's a creator like a guy in
a lab.
It's like making a person inside of a
fucking yes to not not a creator in a
sense of an individual,
but I think that the idea of an
individual became more ridiculous than
anything.
It's like I understand that like what we
are is almost like something filtered
through these predetermined like almost
like we're a membrane,
like something from another dimension
expresses itself through this physical
membrane and then we're almost like the
barrier to what comes out on the other
side that this was the thought that I
had when I was on mushrooms,
that what we are as as as a person is
almost like the the carrier,
like a vehicle for whatever a soul is
and that this thing uses this life to
pass that,
that thing through onto another
experience that happens in the next
dimension that'll be so fucking alien
that you can't even imagine it today in
this dimension and this dimension would
be alien to that dimension that it was
just this never ending infinite process
of soul traveling.
I had this very bizarre,
like thought about like if you,
like people will often say like if you
had to live your life over again,
you are born tomorrow.
You got to do
it all over again.
Could you do it?
You'd be like,
what?
Oh my God,
I got to start over from scratch.
How can I be a baby again and rely on
those same fucking people again?
Oh my God,
I got to go back to first grade.
That was terrible.
That's when my parents broke up and Oh,
and people start freaking out and
thinking,
but you already did it.
You already did it.
What'd you have to do it forever?
Could you do it forever,
forever and ever and ever over and over
and over and over and over again.
Could you do that?
Like reincarnation?
You might be doing that.
That might be just as possible.
What,
what hit me?
Is this just as possible that you've
lived this life and infinite number of
times and you can continue to live this
life and in front number of times.
And when you do,
maybe so you're saying there's a
possibility that we have some kind of
soul type thing,
right?
Some kind of sauce ability that you're
on a loop.
Just like those,
those youtube videos,
are those a instagram videos,
a Cyborg hitting that?
Yeah,
that sweep.
So we're on a lifeline.
If so,
if there is a loop and it say either,
either it's involuntary or voluntary.
Either you say either when you die,
you wake up and go,
Whoa,
that was an awesome ride.
Let's do it again.
Or it just happens automatically.
And you did you get the choice either
way.
Maybe you do,
maybe you don't.
Some spiritual gurus say that,
yes,
some people choose,
some souls choose to keep coming back.
Some stay in the infinite heavens
forever or whatever,
and then come back some every now and
then,
who knows what's real.
But,
um,
you're,
you're talking about there's some kind
of soul thing and there's either a,
you're pro,
you're,
you're saying that this probably an
involuntary reincarnation of some sort.
Yeah.
Right.
So,
so maybe possible.
Maybe either if,
if you decide to come back for sure.
If that's the case,
you would,
you would say,
okay,
I'm going to,
I'm going back in to that earth realm
and you for sure don't want to know
where you came from that it would seem,
I'm guessing that the beauty of life is
after you dying,
you realize what the hell.
Oh,
that's right.
You,
you don't want to know.
It's like watching a movie.
Like I'm,
the other day I watched a movie and I'm
watching the trailer and 30 seconds into
the trailers unsane the movie at 30
seconds I stopped it because I didn't
want to watch the rest of the trailer
because now,
okay,
I got enough.
I want to see this thing.
I didn't want to see more of the trial
because I wanted to go to the movie and
be full.
I didn't want to know what was going on.
I wanted to be confused,
right?
I didn't want to fit,
be able to figure something out from a
trailer.
So,
and most people are like that.
I'm not special.
Like if you went to a movie and you
already saw your buddy didn't and you
told them how it ended,
he would sock you right in the chest.
Fuck you doing.
You just ruined the movie from you.
Faggot.
You know what I mean?
Strong word.
But I mean that I don't mean that in a
homosexual.
I'm sorry.
I'm just trying to be funny and I
apologize to all gay people out there.
I apologize.
I love gay people.
Um,
there was just me trying to express an
emotion,
but a,
and no one's also at the same time going
to go to a movie with the,
have you already signed say dude,
before it starts telling me the whole
movie.
Better
analogies that you never get a chance to
see the future.
You're not going to get a chance to see
the future
once you're reborn again.
This life when you come back,
do you want to have a memory of your
past and you don't,
you don't get it.
It's a part of the system.
I think it's either,
whether it's voluntary or involuntary,
it's best to not know where you came
from at first.
It's best to figure it out.
That's probably what this is all about
is figuring it out.
Cause when we go to the movie,
part of it is it's all about the
journey.
It's not about the destination.
People always use that as a,
you know,
an instagram.
It's not about the journey or thought
about the destination.
It's the journey.
That's one of the most popular saying
it's ever and it's beautiful.
You have to say it every now and then to
remind you,
remind the rum.
Well My,
another thing to remind you,
you don't even think about it as a
journey.
Just be in the moment except the moment
and be in the moment.
Live in the moment thinking about the
future plan for the future,
but exist in the moment.
You know,
don't think of it as a journey or a
destination,
but the people that are the most fucked
or the people that are trying to make it
one day I'm going to make it.
And then when you make,
there's no making.
It never happens.
It doesn't,
it doesn't change.
It doesn't matter if you're an illusion.
I fell for it.
Hook,
line and sinker.
Oh my God.
The the wanting to be a rock star my
whole life.
They got me good.
I wanted that man shit.
Oh,
I was going to have that mansion and
just filled with the shakes and that's
what I was after my whole life.
They got me good.
When I saw kiss and I saw that shit,
I'm like,
I want that.
I knew,
right,
right.
When I saw kiss meets the phantom of the
park,
1978 on NBC,
one of the worst movies of all time.
It just blew me the fuck.
Oh,
he was a power outage.
I was watching it at home and the power
went out and I was devastated.
The weird thing about that,
that Arrow's 1978 and if you followed
kiss,
if you were older,
I was eight and if you followed kiss and
you know from 73 on,
they already had their early cool years
and then after kiss alive that a few
more awesome albums and then they got to
the point where I started doing disco
and that was 1978 that's when I got into
them when they started doing disco.
So I didn't,
I didn't even know what selling out was.
I just heard I was made for loving it
and I loved it.
You know what I mean?
I had no idea.
But um,
man,
I don't even know where my fucking point
was.
What were we talking about?
I don't remember either.
The point was you're never going to get
to know what the future holds.
You just going to be living your life
and that's how it is with everybody.
I don't remember what the fuck your
point was.
Swallow the rockstar thing Roxanne to be
a rock star.
They get you.
They get,
you can,
there's so many different ways they can,
like,
you get your,
you get yourself too.
I mean,
you gotta,
you gotta think about what you're
exposed to,
but look,
it's like,
like music videos,
what they sell in music videos.
They sell that.
It's like they're offering it.
The book I got and a lot of those
rappers that are flashing on the cash,
it's not even their money.
It's not even there,
their mansion.
But it's pushing that you like pushing,
like you want to do whatever it takes,
whatever it takes to make it.
I was so zeroed in on that,
you know me?
Yep.
Up until up until a few years ago,
I was zeroed in on it.
Uh,
then I began to realize,
wow,
they got me real.
God damn good.
You know,
I was obsessed with some,
some,
uh,
an illusion.
Fame is an illusion.
Obsessed with the destination instead of
the journey.
Right.
Well,
I enjoyed the journey,
but it was like you're obsessed with,
it was all about conquering the music
business.
That's all it was about.
And it's not about that anymore,
obviously.
Thank God,
thank God I sucked musically because if
I would've had a record deal and my 20s
shit,
I have did some crazy illuminati shit
back then,
I would did whatever I like,
whatever.
Just I would have been to those parties
with the crazy mask and been doing.
I'm like,
let's go have parties with the crazy
shot.
They just let you think.
Guidewire hit album.
They're like,
hey,
Eddie Brown,
come off California.
Come on down.
Thank God my music sucked because I
would have went along with all that shit
in my twenties I was so obsessed.
I was so obsessed with making it in the
music business.
I would have did any of the home,
but you wouldn't have done that.
Gone part of the Jimmy Savile.
I would have been hanging out with
whoever was famous,
you know shares.
Well,
you know it's like retirement is a
lesser example that people are always
looking to those golden years.
One day I'm going to retire and I with
our hands at the sunset like,
no,
you're thinking about death then we
don't do shit anymore.
You don't have nothing to do.
You know?
The only time you should think about
retirement is if you have a job that you
can retire and they pay you still and
then you can go do whatever the fuck you
want.
That's what you should be thinking about
retiring.
But thinking about is this time where
heindel leave,
we get to relax,
she put our feet up and then they turn
you into soylent green,
turn you in a foot.
That's what you were really green aiming
for and it,
you know,
and everyone is is a working t to get
that vacation and some far away beach
where they can have a beer and the
destination is that they go far away at
least five to eight hours.
You gotta you gotta you can't just use,
you can't just use that to get just,
you have here these beaches don't count
it.
They count for people and not on the
east coast.
They count cause they come here but you
live here so it doesn't count.
You got to get on a flight and get on
it.
Go to a Goddamn beach.
It looks just like Malibu.
Just like you got to trap you.
Got to go across the country go,
you've got to go to Fiji,
the Ocean Masco chasing that beach,
and then what are you gonna do on that
beach?
The first thing you're going to do is
check to see if there's internet as the
first hacking thing you're going to do.
It's an illusion and then every time you
go to the airport you see that picture
of like some dude just lay in there on
some deserted beach.
Like that's even possible.
I thought that was possible.
I thought it might've deserted like a
deserted that you have your own deserted
beach,
you know that your genome,
see that I off camera,
out of the frame of the picture is a
bunch of people trying to sell you a,
an inner tube and some just,
you know,
people trying to rip you off and sell
you shit.
They don't show that part.
They just show your feet,
your feet in a beer.
If you have a perfect beach like that,
you're going to sell it to a bunch of
people.
And it's not just to be this one dude.
Unless you one of those Richard Branson
guys,
that's when you go full or you got your
own beach Wa yes,
yes.
You have that.
Those,
those only exist for Jay z.
You know what I mean?
You've got to buy an island.
Richard Branson type dudes or Tyler
Perry.
He's got an island and it just seems
like these vacations are all like rip
offs.
I remember me and my wife went to Cabo
San Lucas and we looked at the package
and like,
Oh shit,
let's get this resort.
There's five different restaurants.
Amazing.
All inclusive.
This is amazing.
You get there and it's the same kitchen,
five different restaurants,
but only one is open at a time.
They just take different shifts and it's
the same waiters,
the same food.
Oh,
you to come up bunk ass place.
I've got to send you to some good
places.
There's a good place in uh,
in Cabo.
It's called the one and only [inaudible]
never go back there again.
Cabo was amazing.
I love it.
Oh Man.
Everyone's trying to rip you off growing
up.
Yeah,
that happens.
What about Hawaii?
Hawaii.
Yeah.
If someone goes on vacation,
someone gave me a nonstop first class
ticket to Hawaii and a five star hotel
for two weeks,
I wouldn't go.
Why not?
I've traveled so much.
It's an illusion to me.
I want to use up all my shit much.
I want to sit in my house and look out
the window and she'll fuck.
Yeah.
You know,
that's what I want to chill.
I want to be with my family.
I want to be with my son.
That's an illusion.
They have,
you know,
I'm going to travel with my family for
them,
but I've traveled so much.
To me it's an illusion.
I've never been to a place where,
um,
I was pissed that I was leaving.
I was always ready to go.
Like,
dude,
I'm ready.
You want to change our flights and leave
early?
Shit,
when we went to Cabo,
we change our flights and left early.
It sucked.
Wow.
Like what are you gonna sit on a beach?
We got that right here.
We go to Santa Monica.
He had a free vacation we've made.
We got,
me and my family get hotels because my
son loves hotels.
We'll just get a hotel in Burbank,
like a VIP hotel in Burbank where you've
got like this gigantic room and we
stayed there for for a day.
You got to just do w we'll talk after
the podcast.
You can do vacations the right way.
There's ways that you could do go zip
lining in Costa Rica.
Dude,
I got tricked into going to Costa Rica.
I told you that.
I'll never go to Costa Rica ever again.
Okay,
that's good.
Unless it's for a seminar.
I'll go for a seminar.
Like could you just to seminar,
but I ain't trying to go to the jungle
and anything like that.
Fuck that shit.
We've got to wrap this up because I'm
going to Piss my pants.
I've been drinking too much wine.
I throw a plug.
Yes,
me and Sam Tripoli or doing tin foil hat
comedy in San Francisco at Cobb's June
1st and June 2nd at the punchline in
Sacramento.
Uh,
thanks for the shirt.
Oh Shit.
Combat Complex.
The world's Eddie Bravo's birth child
along with Ebi Ebi on a tangent
invitational.
Best fucking Jujitsu tournament in the
world.
But this,
this is the shit combat Jujitsu.
We talked about it many time.
This is going to change Jujitsu,
make it much more applicable to mma
positions on the ground where dudes are
allowed to bitch.
Slap you.
It's strong.
It's crazy.
People love it.
It was the,
it's the fastest Ryan.
He's rising video ever on my youtube
channel.
It got to 300,000 views and like in a
level,
none of my other videos get that kind of
views.
It was crazy.
It's next level.
It shows what,
like these positions where the
vulnerabilities are.
So it's like a real good first step in
MMA is fighting vagner road shop for the
combat Jujitsu world championships.
Ebi,
the next Dbi,
which is in San Diego.
June 24th,
it's a 16 woman,
16 woman tournament plus the Combat
Jujitsu World Championship boogie
against a vagner roadshow.
And we got,
we got amazing women.
We got uh,
all ADCC Ibj Jab champions,
um,
be a basillio.
She's the best checkout there.
Be a mosquito.
And she's the right there at the top.
One more time,
the date.
And what's the website you can watch on
UFC fight pass?
It's going to be or paper view,
inch by inch.
Dot TV.
June 24th Sunday,
June 24th in San Diego.
Tickets go on sale on a couple of weeks
and it's going to be,
it's going to be amazing.
All right.
That's it.
Thank you buddy.
See You tomorrow.
See?
Yeah.
Cool.
Thank you.